[Music]
everybody's got to die but this cemetery
is full of people who have died in their
20s 30s 40s and 50s every one of them
that dies of natural causes died of
nutritional deficiency disease
this is a blind spot for the medical
profession they don't get a single 30
seconds of training and nutrition and as
a result 90% of the people in this
graveyard have died long before their
genetic potential of 120 and 140 but you
know there's a Revolution going on right
now some extraordinary individuals are
going to live to be 150 to 160 that just
sounds incredible are there are there
people that really live oh yes healthc
care is controversial these days maybe
because at some point in our lives we
all need some generally when we feel
sick we run the family doctor for some
pills a quick fix but one doctor is
touring Idaho trying to convince us
there's another way if uh one looked at
the differences between a alternative or
holistic practitioner as opposed to what
you might call a straight or an orthodox
practitioner you might use five or six
different uh things to treat a patient
you might use acupuncture nutrition
herbs and um each one of these sort of
supplement each other they enhance each
other our dogs get 40 minerals our rats
get 28 and our own kids get 12 or less
it's really a dog's life it's these
minerals it's a secret glaciers grind up
these rocks comes out in the form of
glacial milk we're out here surveying
this wheat crop it looks beautiful but
looks are deceiving so it can gain 20
years statistically simply by not going
to medical
school 70% of the medical doctors who
treat Medicare patients plunk the exam
can't uh can't I get the vitamins and
minerals I need from the Fresh Foods
that are available here absolutely
abolutely not so it leaves you open to
diseases far far more horrible than
arthritis in fact today I was in contact
with the oversight committee that
actually called me from the National
Institutes of Health the only way that
you can get certain minerals for
instance selenium and copper and zinc is
to eat liver three times a week Monday
Wednesday Friday and most Americans
aren't going to do that they just don't
like it everybody in the studio is
sticking their tongues out already the
answer is really not more taxes more
Medicaid Medicare the answer lies here
with our food
[Music]
[Applause]
I always like to start out with a little
bit of a survey so I know who I'm
talking to how many of you here tonight
because you thought this was a tax
protest
meeting hey it's an election year it's
going to
happen and then let's see how many of
you grew up in a farm or had anything to
do with livestock sometime in your life
okay great we're going to get along fine
the reason why I asked that last
question I grew up on a bee farm myself
about 80 Mi West to St Louis like
everybody else that raises livestock you
raise a lot of your own feed to stay in
business economically and we raise corn
and soybeans and hay and we'd grind this
stuff up into a flower and we would um
add vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals we'd make pellets and we'd feed
those Cals for about six to nine months
and we'd ship them off to be butchered
and we'd save back the very best ones
for our elves and you'd butcher them in
the barn now the thing that fascinated
me as a teenager was that we ate out of
those same Fields as a family we kept
back five rows of corn we had a garden
at the end of the field where we grow
our peas and beans and squash and
tomatoes and carrots and the part that
fascinated me was I always used to asked
my dad I'd say how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves we grind
up their feed we add vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals make pellets
feed them for six nine months and we
want to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains we eat out of the same
fields and we don't give ourselves the
same vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals well he used to give me a lot
of Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy you're getting Farm
Fresh Food fresh air lots of free
exercise don't ask complicated questions
so I was glad to get rid of the farm
exercise and go to a school at the
University of Missouri and there my
major was in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre but
I didn't get a real answer to my
question until I became a freshman
Veterinary student also at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds is simply
because we don't have insurance for them
we don't have Blue Cross Blue Shield
major medical hospitalization Medicare
medicator Hillary to watch out for them
and if we were to use a human health
care type of system for Animals it'd be
sticker shock for everybody your
hamburger would cost you $275 a pound
boneless skinless chicken breast would
be $450 a pound does eggs be 50 bucks so
we learned that we could keep the cost
of animal products such as meat and
dairy and poultry and eggs down to where
the average person could afford them
simply by reducing or eliminating the
health care cost we do this by
preventing and curing diseases and
animals with nutrition and that whole
concept really fascinated me all through
veterinary school and after graduating
vet school I went to Africa for two
years with Marlon Perkins from the old
Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom days and
got to play Frank Buck for a couple of
years and use the tranquilizer gun and
trample over Central and South Africa
and after two years Marlin sent me a
telegram and invited me back to St Louis
to work on a big project this was in the
early 60s he'd gotten a $7.5 million
Grant to study pollution the environment
the ecology and they needed a Wildlife
veterinarian on the project and my job
was to do autopsies of animals that died
of natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States this of course
included the St Louis Zoo with Perkins
directly the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago
the Bron Zoo New York the national zo
and DC the LA Zoo and many many other
big zoos through throughout the United
States and my job was to do autopsies on
animals that died of natural causes and
to look for a species of animals that
was Ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use canaries
remember how that goes they take a
canary and a little cage down in the
mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide would leak into the mine the
canaries being more sensitive would drop
off the perch and die and give the men a
chance to get out before they suffocated
or blew up we were supposed to set up
colonies of these animals and strategic
locations around the United States and
if they became ill or died from
pollution we would know that there was
some impending environmental Doom that
we had to deal with to save the human
population that was back in the 60s now
after having worked on this project for
some 12 plus years I had done
17,500 autopsies on over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for
comparison and what I learned was that
every animal and every human being who
dies of natural causes Di of a
nutritional deficiency disease and I got
all excited about this nutrition stuff
again and wrote 75 scientific papers for
medical journals Veterinary journals
International pathology journals
contributed chapters to eight
multi-author textbooks on the subject
wrote one of my own it was a thousand
Pages it was 2,000 pictures and I think
it cost 140 bucks each medical students
and Veterinary students had to buy them
to pass the course I don't know if they
ever read them but it was one of those
things they had to buy them to pass the
course so we sold a few of those books
and uh even though I had tried to get
this information out in standard uh
research channels through papers and
lectures and whatnot there's lots of
competition so I I really didn't get the
interest of the people who are in power
either in politics or medical research
although things like 2020 with Hugh DS
and Heraldo I did get to go on that
program before Heraldo got his nose
broke for the first time and uh was in
1700 newspapers throughout the world
with that story and UPI and AP but
really couldn't get anybody interested
we had a lot of competition we just put
men on the moon we had a high-tech cold
war going on with the Soviets we had um
declared war on cancer and committed $23
billion to finding cures and vaccines in
1971 so I became frustrated enough I
went back to school for four years up in
Portland Oregon became a physician and I
practiced there for 12 years as a
general family practitioner and
delivered babies and Seed up chainsaw
wounds took care of hemorrhoids all the
things you do as a general family
practitioner but the thing that gave me
the most pleasure was to use everything
I had learned in Veterinary nutrition on
my human patients and it was no surprise
to me it works just as well in people as
it does in animals now I was always very
honest with my patients I put my
Veterinary degree on the wall next to
the medical degree and they'd come in
and they'd spot that and they say Doc am
I in the right place I'm here for a
physical looks like you're a vet and I'd
say look I won't give you a rabies shot
if you don't deserve
it and if I saw that they were from the
farm on their intake survey I used to
keep one of these ful length obstetrical
gloves you know I'd put that on and kind
of wave it in front of their face like I
was going to examine a maror or a cow
right and I'd put that on or do a little
Ai and their eyes would get as big as
saucers because they knew right what
that was and some of them would panic
and run out the door some of was kind of
like basketball defense you know was
they' never turn their back on me
because they're afraid you
know we had a lot of fun the patients
and I and they taught me a lot of useful
things I like to think I gave them some
useful information we're going to go
over that tonight and if you take home
just 10% % of what I share with you I
believe you're going to save yourself an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you're certainly going to save
yourselves a Gob of money and you're
going to add many many healthful years
to your life if you just take home 10%
now there's no extra charge if you want
to take home 50% or 100% but I'll sleep
well if you take home 10% I always like
to start out by sharing with you that
the human being has the genetic
potential to live healthfully to be 120
to 140 absolutely no doubt about this
everybody body in this room has the
genetic capability to live to be 120 to
140 um unfortunately Americans don't do
a very good job when it comes to
longevity our average lifespan is 75.5
about half of what we're genetically
capable of and in 1990 when the World
Health Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations around the world
for a variety of health things longevity
and so forth um we didn't rank very well
we ranked 17th in longevity amongst the
top 32 First World countries that meant
that there were 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do we ranked
19th in healthfulness that meant there
were 18 other countries whose peoples
live longer than we do before they
developed diabetes and high blood
pressure and heart disease and arthritis
and and cancer we ranked 23rd when it
came to live birth and first year
survivability of babies and we ranked
dead last 32nd out of 32 when it comes
to preventing birth effects and what all
these statistics mean is that we have
the highest priced health healthare
system in the world but not the best and
you're a witness to that if everything
was perfect with your health or the
health of your loved ones if everything
was perfect with the health care System
you'd be home doing something else
tonight and so just the fact that you're
interested to get additional information
for your health for the health of a
loved one says a lot it's a testimony uh
for what's going on in the Health Care
system
today now everybody has some little
ritual that they do on a regular basis
whether it's daily or several times a
day or several times a week that they
believe will add healthful years to
their life and it ranges from doing
exercise meditation yoga things like
wearing Bergen stocks there's things
like um being a vegetarian juicing
ripping the chicken skin off your
chicken taking an aspirin every day all
these various things that we're told to
do and Grandma passes down groups of
herbs to you combinations and so on
let's have a look at three or four and
see if there's any proof in the pudding
that there's any real benefit to these
things and let's start out with what is
called the Paleo lifestyle this is where
you're supposed to live and eat like a
caveman you're supposed to eat
everything raw raw vegetables raw grains
you can't eat any Iowa cornfed beef you
have to chase down lowfat antelopes with
your Bergen stocked feet and choke them
to death with your bare hands because
you know a gun and bow and arrow are
inhumane so let's see if there's any
proof in the pudding that there's any
benefit to that type of
lifestyle and the only real hard
evidence we have here is old ai ai of
course was a mummified corpse was found
in the ell Valley of the Italian Alps
when a glacier melted and receded
farther than it had any time in human
history and when they examined this
fellow's corpse they found out that he
was in the Primal life when he died
somewhere between 25 and 40 years of age
they knew he was from the copper age
because all of his tools and weapons on
his person were pure copper and that
ranged between four and 6,000 years ago
and the part of this thing that
fascinated me was they did a carbon
dating on his tissues and narrowed it
down that he had died 5,300 00 years ago
and they did a series of x-rays on him
to see if he had any of the degenerative
diseases that plague Modern Man things
like cancer and uh tuberculosis things
like oh syphus and so on what they found
out was this he had severe degenerative
arthritis of the cervical vertebrae of
his neck lumbar vertebrae of his lower
back and both hips additionally he had
hardening of the arteries he had
coronary artery disease he had hardening
of the arteries arteriosclerosis of the
AR to pulmonary artery and of the iliac
arteries going down into both of his
legs and I guarantee you he didn't eat
three eggs for breakfast every morning
certainly didn't eat any Big Macs he
didn't eat any Iowa cornfed beef all of
the things that are blamed on these
types of degenerative diseases so there
is no proof in the pudding that the
Paleolithic lifestyle has any health or
longevity benefit then there's the
meditation and yoga the body mind Spirit
thing that was brought to the United
States during the 60s and 70s by the
flower children the hippie kind of died
out for a while and has been reawakened
in the last couple of years by Deep choa
who's written I don't know at least five
bestselling books on the subject let's
see if there's any proof in the pudding
that meditation and yoga have any
longevity or health benefit Rita Gara
age 55 and and thought to be the premier
meditation and yoga instructor in the
Western Hemisphere um was the director
of the Himalayan Institute in Chicago
she was a vegan a type of vegetarian
that doesn't eat any animal products
whatsoever and she thought she was so
spiritually elevated she didn't need to
supplement any of her diet diet with
vitamins and minerals and as a result
she died at age 55 from a simple
deficiency of a trace mineral called
selenium a cardiomyopathy heart attack
so there's no proof in the pudding that
the body mind Spirit approach meditation
and yoga has any health or longevity
benefit can calm you down during tax
season and finals week but no Health and
Longevity benefit then there's this
organic food movement which has been
around since Adele Davis and people
mistakenly believe that organically
grown food is is healthier for are you
uh from the standpoint of nutrition than
is non-organically grown food and
organic means it's just grown without
sprays no herbicides or pesticides and
certainly it's safer from the standpoint
of cancer but what about everything else
well certainly it doesn't work very well
because it just means there's no sprays
on it it says nothing there's no
warranty or guarantee that there's more
vitamins or minerals in there there was
a guy who wrote two best selling books
on the subject The Secret Lives of
plants and the secrets of the soil his
name was Chris bird Christopher bird I'd
known him for 25 years and I I used to
give him as a present I would just give
him minerals and things trying to save
his life cuz he had snow white here and
we'll talk about that in a minute and he
just poo pooed he says I'm eating
organically grown food I don't need to
take anything else and I was in about
three weeks ago I was in the airport in
Atlanta reading the local newspaper and
guess whose obituary is in there in big
bold letters Christopher bird wrote The
Secret life's of plants and the secrets
of the soil 68 years old he drops dead
from a stroke even though he was eating
nothing but organically gr own food so
there is no proof in the pudding that
that in of itself has any health or
longevity benefit then there's the
subject of meat A lot of people say oh
you can't live to be healthful if you
eat a lot of meat you got to give up
meat you have to be a vegan or a
vegetarian of some type or another and
I've listened to that for years and of
course my personal Credo is that a day
without a hamburger is like a day
without
Sunshine so I was happy to see this I
was up in Colorado last week and uh they
found it in Colorado there's 400 people
over the age of 100 they 105 and 109 and
and so forth there's 400 people over the
age of 100 and the only Common Thread
they're different races and different
religions have different dietary
Lifestyles but the only Common Thread
between all these 400 people who are
over age 100 they're heavy meat eaters
they're heavy meat eaters is the only
Common Thread so yes for us
mediators then there's see you got guys
it was worth your coming here tonight
wasn't
it then there's this salt thing you know
everybody oh you got to give up salt
because it causes high blood pressure if
you have high blood pressure got to give
up salt what's the first thing a good
farmer puts out for his livestock it's
about that big it's a salt block right
and of course I refuse to believe that
my patients are dumber than an old cow
and so I used to tell them hey just go
ahead and take all the salt you want and
people would shrink and and Terror and
say wallak you're you're flying in the
face of all the weight of medical
evidence you're going to kill people
telling them to Salt their food and of
course there never is there never was
and there never will be any weight of
medical evidence that said salt is bad
for you it certainly does not cause high
blood
pressure this came out just a couple of
days ago May 22nd Wednesday May 22nd
just about a week ago now and there was
a study that was done that came out in
jamama the Journal of the American
Medical Association the most
prestigious medical journal in the world
they looked at 56 studies that have been
done around the world on salt and high
blood pressure and they combined them
into one study and some doctors from
Toronto Medical School up at the
University of Toronto researched all
this and they said hey people who have
normal blood pressure there's no benefit
to restricting your salt intake it does
not protect you from high blood pressure
if you have high blood pressure only 5%
of the people with high blood pressure
get any benefit from restricting salt
only 5% and then they only reduce their
blood pressure by 3.7 millimeters of
mercury if your blood pressure is up 25
30 40 points it's kind of stupid to give
up salt for other reasons um because it
has nothing to do positively for your
health what he did say over here was
that there's so many doctors that have a
vested interest in getting people off
the salt that they told them to get off
of salt you have to keep coming in and
getting medicine and water pills and
this that and the other why would they
tell you to go ahead and salt your food
and stay home and enjoy yourself you
know and so there is no proof in the
pudding that getting salt out of your
diet has any health or longevity benefit
one more then we'll get into the
longevity thing this last one is the
subject of the Mediterranean diet this
is the one that the medical profession
has jumped on they say the Mediterranean
diet is the answer for the Health and
Longevity and Optimal Health and what
they want you to do is give up red meat
and eat lots of chicken and poultry and
lots of fruit and vegetables a little
wine was okay according to the
Mediterranean diet but there is no proof
in the pudding that it has any health or
longevity benefit because the Greeks and
the Italians who eat the most of it live
to be 75.5 just like
us and here's a hard
example Pope John Paul II of course
is the pope of all the Catholics and and
big Catholic population in Italy and
you'd like to think that if anybody in
Italy was getting the very best that the
Mediterranean diet would have to offer
to be the pope he's 76 years old just
turned 76 years old two years ago had
his hips replaced because of
degenerative arthritis and osteoporosis
he has failing Health he has to cancel
half of his speaking engagements and
half of his administrative duties he
just simply does not have enough
strength to do that anymore and 76 is
about half of what we're genetically
capable of when it comes to longevity so
unless he's been sneaking in poy sausage
under the table for the last 17 years
since he's been in Rome there is no
proof in the pudding that the
Mediterranean diet has any health or
longevity benefit let's have a look at
just how old you can live to be if you
do everything right is it worth going to
a little effort I I believe it is and
I'm going to prove it to
you Christian Mortenson here in August
of
1995 about uh what almost nine months
ago now turned 113 plays golf once a
week look looks like he's about 85 years
old looks pretty good for
113 and this gal here Dora rbe from
South Africa turned 114 in July of 1995
and when the media and the Press ran to
her and said Dora what do you attribute
Your Health and Longevity to she did not
say I owe it all to my
HMO she did not say hey I never failed
to take that invitation and go in for my
annual physical what she said was this I
eat Locust every day you know
grasshoppers uh pumpkin seeds tortoise
meat not a vegetarian wild herbs dried
fruit and starts each day with a cup of
coffee so we're beginning to connect the
dots and put together what it takes to
live to be over a
100 don't rush to the bait store because
crickets won't work it has to be
grasshoppers this gal here Jean
cment from France in February February
21st 1995 turned 120 and was documented
by the Guinness World Book records as
being the oldest living woman in the
world and she rode her bike until she
was 105 years of age and volunteered as
a librarian in the Paris Library and
then a year later February 21st 1996
just a couple months ago she turned 121
and she's still documented as the oldest
living woman in the world by the
Guinness World Book of Records this
fellow here from little town outside of
bogal Columbia his name was uh or is
he's still alive Francisco barison noo
Cho Arina uh when he was asked by
reporters what did he attribute his
Health and Longevity to he said that he
drinks a gallon of goats milk every day
and the part that fascinated me about
his birthday story is that 40 years ago
his doctors told him he only had a
couple of months to live and his son's
built him a coffin and every morning for
40 years he's been waking up sitting by
that coffin waiting to die night time
comes he goes to bed wakes up sits by
the coffin waiting to die he's been
doing that every morning for 40 years
because doctor told him he was going to
die in a couple of months probably
didn't have a calendar you know
just and of course all the doctors who
told him that 40 years ago are long
since
dead in addition to Turning 125 and
still going strong uh he was still
fathering children at age 90 so there's
hope for some of you guys going to sleep
in the back of the room
already this G here mumi Dy from Iran
according to the Iranian news agency
this was in the Rocky Mountain news from
Denver a little over about a year and a
half ago now January 1995 she died at
age of 161 and the interesting thing
about her obituary to me is that she was
survived by six living children ranging
in age from 120 to
128 they had never even left home to go
to college
yet and her oldest son Golam said his
mother had never visited a doctor or
taken any chemical medications or drugs
or Pharmaceuticals did take a few herbs
during her life so again we're beginning
to collect more information of what it
takes to live to be over 100 now let's
look at a a fellow from the United
States who's a favorite son of course I
believe especially for people who are
interested in Alternative Health lannis
Pauling lannis Pauling uh was famous for
a variety of reasons number one he is
one of two people to ever get two
unshared Nobel prizes certainly one of
the Geniuses of our Century maybe of all
time he was also famous for his interest
in vitamin C
and he was trained in classical
biochemistry and nutrition in medical
schools and and universities and so he
believed you could get all of your
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
amino acids and fatty acids from eating
your four food groups but he also
believed that you needed to take extra
vitamin C because of the pollution in
our air water and food and because of
all the stresses of modern-day life and
so he personally took 10,000 milligrams
of Vitamin C every day for 35 years
never missed a lick 10,000 milligrams of
Vitamin C every day for 35 years and he
still died 7even years short of the
magic number of 100 died at age of 93
and he died of widely disseminated
prostate cancer well after reading all
of his materials and scientific articles
and in nutritional journals and
Physiology journals and so on and an
additional 400 articles by various
authors on vitamin C here's what I can
guarantee you if you Faithfully take
10,000 milligrams of Vitamin C every day
for 35 years like lonus Pauling did and
you're a woman I will guarantee you that
you will never get prostate
cancer that's the only guarantee I can
make about vitamin C there's absolutely
no doubt that the human being can live
to be 120 to 140 people do it all the
time that for spending many many years
perhaps 30 years looking and reading and
studying on Health and Longevity in both
Veterinary journals and human medical
journals here's what I can tell you no
matter how you look at Health and
Longevity there's really only two basic
concepts that you have to be concerned
with Concept number one I refer to as uh
avoid stepping on the landmines this is
where you don't want to throw away your
life wastefully you don't want to smoke
you don't want to abuse alcohol
certainly don't do drugs don't jog down
the highway at 2 o'clock in the morning
wearing an all black ninja suit you're
going to get hit by a truck mirror right
uh you don't want to jump out of a hot
air balloon from 250 foot up with a 300
foot bungee cord the math doesn't work
out then there's a lot of crazy things
people do uh certainly lastly I would
say you want to avoid going to a medical
doctor because given half a chance they
will kill
you now as flippant as this might sound
to some of you and I know there may be
some health professionals in here
tonight and I applaud you for being here
if you are this happens to be from April
14th 1996 the Sunday supplement magazine
Parade Magazine many newspapers around
America and they did a whole special
issue on when doctors are the problem
I've been talking about this for 25
years years and so this is they're kind
of what 25 years late but better late
than never in this case in in April
excuse me in January January 13th of
1993 January 13th 1993 Ralph nater came
out the results of a three-year study on
hospitals and and deaths and infections
and injuries that occurred in those
hospitals 1500 pages and uh there's all
kinds of things that he said but I'm
going to give you one of the bottom
lines which just was a shocker to me he
said quote 300,000 Americans are killed
each year in hospitals alone as a result
of medical negligence unquote
300,000 to appreciate how big a figure
that is remember he used the word killed
that means that somebody did something
to them to dispatch them they didn't
just die accidentally they were killed
according to Ralph nater not me let's
compare that with 10 years of of
military operations in Vietnam and over
that 10 years we had lost 56,000
military personnel for an average of
5,600 a year and for these military
losses millions of people poured out in
the streets and protested we had
political Anarchy the last three years
of that 10-year War we chased a
president out of the presidency and God
forgive us we shot and killed American
students in Kent State Ohio
demonstrating against that war this was
for 5,600 military personnel a year now
comes Ralph nater and says here's one
profession or one trade who kills
300,000 Americans a year through
negligence and you can't even find a
crazy Street Preacher out here in any
Conor protesting it well who is it that
they kill kill is it just the homeless
they go under the bridges and you know
things like that and get the the
homeless and take them to the teaching
hospitals take them down in the
basements and practice on them it's not
that simple of course it's a little more
complicated uh well let's see we got 600
or plus people in here tonight how many
of you remember Betsy Layman anybody
remember the name Betsy Layman okay not
a single soul I'm going to remind you
who Betsy Layman was just about a year
ago April of 19 uh
995 um
Betsy Layman uh who was the Pulitzer
Prize winning medical reporter from the
Boston Globe the second largest
newspaper in America 39 years old
developed breast cancer and she sat down
by her computer and scientifically
examined all the cancer treatment
centers in the world not just her own
Hometown and she looked at the
successful ones and who had terrible
safety records and who was on The
Cutting Edge of of research for breast
cancer and she chose the Dana Farber
Cancer Institute in Boston as her cancer
treatment center and she went in for her
first and what turns out to be her last
chemotherapy treatment they killed her
with a 16 times
overdose they gave her 4-day dose every
day for four days and they killed her
now because she was famous she was
written up in Time Magazine and in every
newspaper uh in America because again
she was a Pulitzer prizewinning medical
reporter for the Boston Globe but
remember there was still
299,999 Americans killed in 1995 by the
medical profession according to Ralph
nater she was just one that was
highlighted now this one here I'm going
to share this last one with you and I
want to absolve everybody involved with
this presentation tonight including the
Civic Center and yourselves and any
company involved and so forth this is my
own personal thing and if anybody gets
arrested sued or assassinated it will be
me so you're absolved of any of this
danger you recognize this gal here as a
photograph little fuzzy because I lifted
it out of a magazine and the reason why
I like this photograph of Jackie Kennedy
is that it was taken of her 3 days
before she entered the hospital in New
York for her first and what turned out
to be her last chemotherapy treatment
for cancer she was taking a stroll in
this picture in in Central Park in New
York in a Brisk day with a friend and um
she was diagnosed 6 months before her
death as having non-hodgkin lymphoma
which is a type of cancer that normally
takes 10 12 15 years to kill you it's
relatively painless say in comparison to
pancreatic cancer which can kill you in
3 to six months and be excruciatingly
painful
and when she went in for her first
chemotherapy treatment there was no
death watch on her because there was no
anticipation she was going to die after
all she had 10 12 15 years left to go
goes in on Friday night Tuesday she's
dead and you're supposed to believe that
Jackie Kennedy died of cancer well as a
pathologist and a clinician I'll
guarantee as sure as God made little
green apples Jackie Kennedy did not die
of
cancer she died of an overdose of
chemotherapy just like Betsy
Layman and if they can kill a Jackie
Kennedy and they can kill a Betsy Layman
and not a single thing happened to any
of those doctors they weren't sued they
weren't dismissed their licenses weren't
suspended nothing happened to those
clinics or hospitals what chance does
the average person out in the street
have not very
much now here's another survey that
Ralph nater did in July of 1994 in this
one he looked at the relationship
between Doctors medical doctors and
seniors people over age 65 this happens
to be from the front page of the USA
Today I just like the color pictures it
was in every newspaper in America and
what this study said was this 70% of the
doctors who treat Medicare patients
flunk the exam on how to prescribe to
the elderly safely and effectively 70%
flun the exam now what would happen to
American Airlines if 70% of their pilots
flunk the exam on how to
fly what would happen to American
Airlines if they killed 300,000
passengers a year you see all this big
hoo-ha going on over the Value Jet where
they killed 109 people right now the
reason why this difference is this when
a jet goes down and splash matters parts
of people's bodies you know say 200
passengers over a hillside or a swamp
it's pretty hard to hide and so you know
it's a kind of a gruesome thing but in
the medical profession is more subtle
than that obviously if doctors were to
line up cancer patients and and AIDS
patients and people with diabetes along
the wall and M them down with a machine
gun to save money for treatment then
people would protest because that's very
blatant but here's one of the many
examples that Ralph nater gave as to why
this is missed because people are busy
with their lives you have kids and
grandkids you have jobs and and things
to do and so you're not going to sit
there and kind of keep an eye on things
you assume that somebody else is doing
it well here's what Ralph nater said
32,000 hip fractures each year in
America are attributed to prescriptions
or prescribing by medical doctors that
leaves the elderly sedated and
unbalanced and they fall over and
Fracture a hip trying to avoid stepping
on the kid or getting out of the tub
getting out of the car and this is a
death sentence for 29,000 of these
people remember 75% over the age of 65
don't live 90 days they die of
complications pneumonia uh stroke and
pulmonary embolism and others and I
believe that doctors should be held
responsible for this just the way that
um bartenders are when they let people
drink too much and drive home and kill
somebody else or themselves and there's
manslaughter and second deegree murder
and wrongful death however you know
whatever applies to that case and there
is an organization called mad Mothers
Against Drunk drivers because there's
15,000 Americans every year killed by
drunk drivers any members of mad in this
audience tonight mad members yeah
there's a couple any rate I believe they
should redirect their energies towards
Physicians because Physicians according
to Ralph nator kill 300,000 Americans a
year and they don't even have to change
their towels or their letterhead they
could keep their initials mad just
change their name to Mothers Against
dumb
doctors yes thank
you yeah a couple more in concept number
one I think you'll have the idea idea um
one of my favorite surveys that was done
by Harvard Medical School was published
in 1972 what they did was look at the
the drug use both the illegal street
drug use and the illegal use of
prescription drugs by medical doctors on
themselves on a weekly basis what they
found out was pretty shocking they found
out that 52% of licensed medical doctors
in America use psychotrophic drugs on
themselves each and every week this
included cocaine marijuana speed
barbituates opium derivatives and things
like fent now so what that means is if
you choose to go to a doctor for every
little thing when you leave here tonight
don't be too excited about their degrees
and certificates and and licenses
hanging on the wall what you want to do
is very carefully look at the pupils of
their
eyes and see if they're gorked out on
something before you let them examine
you or uh prescribe to you or do any
kind of procedures even scarier to me is
that 78% of the medical students in
America use psychotrophic drugs on
themselves illegally each week and down
deep in your heart do you really believe
that when they graduate school and go
out and practice do they quit using
drugs no they can get the good stuff now
because they're making money
right here's an example I have thousands
of these but here's an
example Dr Michael a potler 30 years old
just about three years out of his
residency we knew he was a kind of
Doctor Who was going to be in trouble
because he's wearing Bergen stocks
right now now he killed himself an
overdose of of um drugs and you know he
gave himself an intravenous injection a
recreational thing and killed himself
because he was a medical doctor they
eulogized him on the front page of the
San Diego newspaper he saved the lives
of children but lost his own and in the
article said he devoted his whole life
to caring for children now unless he was
a babysitter or a pedophile most of his
life that had to be a lie because he was
only out of his residency for three
years additionally he was a thief
because of drugs he killed himself with
he stole out of the hospital pharmacy he
was additionally malignant
dumb because after 14 years of medical
school he still couldn't read the
syringe right and killed himself with an
overdose I mean these kids who drop out
of high school and can't even read right
and do math live in cardboard boxes they
do drugs every year forever and ever and
ever and don't kill
themselves this is from the editorial
page of the Washington Post Washington
DC November 2nd 1992 lining docks
Pockets if you go to a doctor your
doctor you want him to think of you as a
patient not a cash cow but two studies
in this month's New England Journal of
Medicine shows that doctors are out to
milk you dry and if you're from a farm
you know what that means what a cash cow
is 10 months later in the reader digest
very interesting article of September
1993 and to me the reader digest is the
sweetest little magazine that ever was
never never says anything negative about
any one or any individual or any group
and so I was really surprised to see
this and on page 77 it says can you
trust your doctor and it lists 12 ways
that doctors routinely scam patients
I'll give you the worst one you can go
look up the other 11 September 1993 the
worst one according to Readers Digest
not me the average doctor in America
gets $421 in Kickbacks every time he
refer somebody in for a CAT scan or an
MRI and you thought doctor loved you and
he said you know we've been fighting
that btis and that shoulder for 5 years
and give heroic injections of cortisone
in there and it's just getting worse
let's you know you've got good insurance
and you got good Medicare supplement not
going to cost you anything let's run you
in and see if that bir ctis is really
arthritis to Ching 421 bucks now
according to Readers Digest not Joel
wallik the average doctor in America
gets
$226,600 CAT scan Kickbacks and you
wonder why healthc care cost keep
spiraling
upwards now the best way to keep track
of doctors and keep a scorecard on them
is to look at the obituaries in your
town uh it's not gruesome but you should
look in there and if everybody is dying
in their 50s that should give you some
concern you know everybody should be
dying in their 80s and 90s and hundreds
if everybody's dying of kidney disease
you don't want to go to the urologist in
your town so you know just kind of take
a glance through the obituaries and see
if there's any kind of picture that's
developing
here but a year year and a half ago this
obituary appeared in the San Diego
newspaper and is it's a national level
tragedy obituary Grace M age 48 died of
widely disseminated breast cancer
horrible thing it used to be a disease
of older women today it's a disease of
teenage girls it's one of those things
that's gotten worse over the years and
there's a variety of reasons for this
but certainly chemotherapy and radiation
has not solved the problem but anyway
this little headline here given
radiation as a baby I want to know what
that had to do with her obituary so I
read her obituary and says when she was
6 months of age
her pediatrician shrank her thymus gland
with radiation from an x-ray machine
because he didn't know what else to do
she was kind of a sickly kid and they
you know they took out her tonsils or
adenoids and well there's nothing else
to do let's just shrink her thyroid or
excuse me her thymus gland what a
terrible thing to do who on Earth would
do such a thing everybody knows your
thymus gland is there to activate your
killer tea cells and protect you from
viruses and cancer and that sort of
thing nobody in the right mind would do
such a thing so I went into the medical
literature between 1945 and 1950 and
looked at all the pediatric medical
journals and sure enough it was common
practice back then because the Army and
Navy and had given all the medical
doctors in America free x-ray machines
when they closed down all these field
hospitals and this that and the other
and they gave these Mobile X-Ray
machines all the doctors hey go out and
try them doc you know you're a doctor
and uh it was common practice and
according to the US Department of energy
one million American babies under the
age of one year had their thymus gland
shrunk between 1945 and 1950 1 million
not a single foreign enemy has ever
radiated in America neither civilian or
military and the one profession who says
well trust me my dear radiated 1 million
American babies now according to the
American or the US Department of energy
these kids have either already died of
cancer they're currently under treatment
for cancer or they project they're going
to die of cancer based on the amount of
radiation they received to their neck
and chest to shrink their thymus
glands now you wonder what the pupils
look like on the eyes of this surgeon up
in Grand Rapids Michigan about a year
ago when he took off the normal breast
and left the Cancer's one on no sober
surgeon can make that mistake I mean
even if he was dyslexic he couldn't make
that
mistake because if he's dyslexic the
surgical nurses know that and they'll
take a red wax pencil and put a bullseye
on the correct breast and put a red
ribbon on the guy's wrist and say Doc
just match the colors even a dyslexia
can match colors so you know this guy
had to be gorked out on
something and uh the poster child as it
turns out for Americans who've been
injured and killed in American hospitals
turns out to be a name of a guy by the
name of Willie King Willie King went
into the university community hospital
in Tampa Florida to get his right leg
amputated he had uncontrolled diabetes
he had gr Gang Green and that leg the
bones were sticking out of his toes his
skin was slipping off and his flesh
smell like rotten meat in a garbage can
on a hot July night and the surgeons
promptly cut off his normal left
leg now it turned out okay for will
because they cut off his other leg for
free kind of balanced him up a little
bit couple more and I think you'll have
the picture Dr Raymond Satler a
neurosurgeon from North Carolina uh got
his license suspended for 30 days
according to this article because he
left the surgical room after he had
exposed the patient's brain to the air
he left the patient's brain exposed for
25 minutes and dried out a little bit
and well he ran out and got some lunch
now I don't believe that was the case
because I've done a lot of surgery and
when you get to the point where you're
kind of dancing around you know when you
have to go to the bathroom or you're
hungry it's not the sort of thing that
you're going to leave a patient what you
do is you go faster you you put the
stitches farther apart you put a fewer
in but you get it done before you leave
and I believe that this fellow is one of
those 52% of the medical doctors who do
drugs every week and had to run into the
bathroom and snort some cocaine or give
himself an injection to calm himself
down and I based this opinion on remarks
and statements from the Medical Board of
North Carolina and they said Dr Raymond
Satler forgot the names of surgical
instruments during the operation and
told his nurse to drill holes in the
patient's head with a Black and Decker
drill I was like seious home
repair and she didn't know what she was
doing she injures the patient so he got
his license suspended for 30 days this
fellow here is a chess surgeon in Fort
Worth Texas uh he was on the staff of
the osteopathic medical center of Texas
and um uh took out the normal right lung
and left the cancerous left lung in
I guarantee you he immediately knew that
because whenever you remove something
that has cancer in it you always take
your scalpel and you cut through it
several times take a representative
sample put it in some preservative and
send it to the lab so they can tell you
exactly what's going on there so you
know how to pursue treatment so this guy
knew immediately and of course didn't
tell anybody says well nobody will know
well it just so happens that this uh
patient went in for autopsy after he
died and the pathologist said wait a
minute the results here at the autopsy
don't jive with a surgical record and so
just to kind of keep things quiet the
surgeon settled for $9 million with the
family never going to a jury and why
would he do that why wouldn't he spend
$250,000 worth of of um uh legal fees
when the uh his malpractice insurance
would pay for that would pay for those
legal fees and get it down to 5 million
or 4 million or 2 million he didn't do
that well the reason is I guarantee you
he couldn't find another physician or a
nurse who would testify that he was
sober during the procedure and if that
would have gone before a jury the reward
to the family would have been a hundred
million so he was lucky and glad to get
off with a $9 million
settlement now one of the things that I
think should should be standard and
taught in medical schools is what a dead
patient looks like what alive patient
looks like that should be standard Death
101 life 101 those should be standard
courses but you're never quite sure that
they have this kind of information when
you see stuff like
this this gal here Mildred C Clark 86
years old was found cold stiff and blue
on a nursing home apartment apartment
floor and the house doctor came in and
couldn't find a pulse in respiration he
said well she's dead she's 86 years old
let's not go to any heroic efforts here
and run the bills up for the family and
make her miserable in the last few
moments of her life so I threw her body
in the meat wagon and send her off to a
morg at a little Hospital in Albany New
York but the house doctor is not going
to let you put a body in the morg
without a death death certificate so he
comes down examines her again couldn't
find a a pulse respiration declares her
dead writes a death certificate turns
her body over to the morg technician who
promptly strips her body down down hoses
her down with water to clean her up puts
her in a body bag and he Wheels her into
a freezer for 90 minutes until the
pathologist gets there to do the autopsy
an hour and a half in the freezer the
pathologist and carnor show up so he
Wheels the body out of the freezer Zips
open the body bag and she sits up she
says thank God you found
me it was cold and dark in there and I
didn't know where I
was now she had to be a tough old
bird if you don't believe so get naked
hose yourself down get in the freezer
with the ice cream for 90 minutes and
see how well you
do about five years ago all the medical
doctors in the world got together at a
big International Convention and they
wanted to do a study and find out what
it was that drove certain patients to
give up money you know when something
happened and and the doctor tried to
settle out of court wave of one million
check in front of people's face $1
million taxfree these people say no
money doesn't matter I'm going to take
this doctor before a jury and show that
he's a quack and a fraud and a butcher
and all that sort of stuff they want to
know what it was that turned the
patient's button on to get him to do
that what they found out was this it's
always a patient who felt slided when
they were in pain or in trouble and the
doctor then did something wrong and hurt
them and this doctor was one who was
Notorious for coming in the the
examining room you're laying there in
your gown or naked on the on the couch
or the examining table and um kept
looking at your watch and looked at the
record never touched the patient or
shook their hand or talked them directly
in their eyes but just looked at the
record and say okay I'm going to write
your prescription ran out the door and
calling to his nurse to get his car up
because he had a golf appointment these
are the ones that patients just wanted
to go after them and you shouldn't be
too surprised that this is the approach
that the medical profession has taken to
prevent those types of
Suits this is from the Lance at the top
British medical journal the top
International medical journal and was
two professors of medical ethics from
the medical school at the University of
Western Ontario up in
Canada and what they said was this
acting classes should be required in
medical schools so doctors can learn
just when to provide a perfectly time
compassionate look or a touch on the
hand and that was supposed to avoid all
these suits where patients thought the
doctors didn't like them so if you go to
a doctor for every little thing you
don't know if they're acting or not they
don't even you don't even know if they
know if you're alive or dead you don't
know if they're gork out on something or
sober you don't know if they're going to
give you one of those 70% of the
prescriptions that are going to kill you
these are all reasons why you want to
avoid stepping on the landmines get as
much information as you can yourself
make as many of your own decisions as
you can save yourself unnecessary risk
that's concept number one concept number
two these are all the positive things
that most of you are here for tonight
these are the positive things that you
can do to direct yourself towards
reaching 120 to 140 and basically what
you want to do is give your body all of
the raw materials it require to maintain
and repair itself most of us don't think
in those terms we require maintenance
materials just like any machine if you
will that tractor can you run a tractor
or a car without coolant and oil no you
wouldn't think of it and yet uh you know
the equivalent we try to do that for own
B so let's look at what we need to
maintain oursel and repair ourself we
need 90 essential nutrients 60 that's 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
and the reason why these things are
called essential nutrients
is twofold number one our bodies cannot
manufacture them we must consume them
every day either in food or supplements
and number two if any one of these
essential nutrients is missing for 6
months 12 months a year two years guess
what happens you get on the average 10
deficiency diseases 10 deficiency
diseases times 90 essential nutrients
that's 900 diseases that are preventable
with proper supplementation and the nice
part of this story is if you've had any
of these deficiency diseases for 5 10 10
15 20 30 years and you start
supplementing because you just learn
about this you have every honest
expectation of getting significantly
better maybe even 100% better so you
have everything to gain and nothing to
lose by considering this now as we've
learned tonight the media is interested
in what you're interested in because it
sells newspaper so to speak they sell a
lot of newspaper if they have a nice
story and everybody runs out to get one
if you hear a radio program that
everybody's interested in uh they sell
more advertisement so this is why you
hear a lot of health programs on Radio
and on TV and you see it in newspapers
magazines and my personal favorite of
all the health articles was this one
here April 6 1992 a little over four
years ago it was the first time that the
subject of vitamins and minerals was
treated in a positive way by any
mainstream publication Time Magazine no
less cover says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of Aging prior to this article
mainstream magazines would only say
things like well vitamins and minerals
are quackery and hoax and fraud
charlatanism nobody needs those things
you can get everything you need from
your four food groups now if you haven't
read that article again April 6th 1992
I'd urge you to go to a Library Public
Library School library dig it out and
read it there was six positive
Pages there was only one negative
sentence and as you might guess it was
offered by a medical doctor who was
asked by the writer of the article what
do you think about vitamins and minerals
for human nutrition here's what he said
quote popping vitamins doesn't do any
good sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a
professor of medicine at New York York
City's Mount siai medical school we get
all the vitamins we need in our diets
and taking supplements just gives you
expensive urine unquote now Missouri
translation of that is you're just
peeing away your
money might as well W up your dollars
and throw them in the toilet and flush
them away you know you get everything
you need from your for food groups that
little sentence has killed more
Americans than all of the foreign
enemies with their rifles and artillery
put together you can get everything you
need from your for food group it is not
true believe me it's not true now and I
can guarantee you after having done
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison having practiced for 12 years
in Portland Argan as a general family
practitioner pushing 60 myself and
having kids this tall and grandkids this
big and not too distant future
great-grandkids I'd rather pee out 50
cents or a dollar a day wor of excess
vitamins and minerals that's cheap
insurance if you don't invest 50 cents
to a dollar a day in yourself as sure as
God made gr little green apples you're
going to invest in the lifestyle of a
medical doctor because when you pay them
hard cash out of your own pocket or
indirectly through insurance or
indirectly through taxes and Medicare
that a single penny of that goes to
better understand manage treat prevent
or cure catastrophic diseases in kids
breast cancer in women prostate cancer
in men diabetes heart disease cataract
it pays the doctor's mortgage pays the
doctor's mortgage no matter how you're
struggling with your bills it pays the
doctor's mortgage and when you pay the
doctor after the second week of the
month you're paying his Mercedes payment
you pay the doctor after after the third
week of the month you're paying the
tuition for their kids to go to medical
school at Harvard our worst yet Yale law
school so always need is a bunch more
Yale lawyers running around we got a
whole White House full of them and look
what's going on in
there thank
[Applause]
you oh we could get into that I mean
that's why they call me the rush limbo
of Alternative Health
okay now one of the things that I used
to do for my patients was send them a
two-cent photocopy of little articles
I'd find in newspapers and nutritional
journals and medical and Veterinary
journals things that they could do
themselves nutritionally or with herbs
or whatnot and it got to be quite a
thing 250,000 people a month one of
these two cent photocopies so I turn it
into a magazine that comes out every
couple of months but I'm going to show
you what I used to give my patients and
what you two can can get um let's start
out with cancer the number two killer of
uh adles United States if you take
nothing else home tonight but this piece
of information it was worth your
coming this little
study was done by the National Cancer
Institute and they went to henan
Province China for five years they chose
henan Province China because it has the
highest rate of cancer and cancer deaths
in the whole world they took 29,000
apparently healthy people ranging in age
from 40 to 69 and they divided them up
into little groups and gave each group a
different Vin Vin different minerals
sometimes combinations of vitamins and
minerals and after 5 years they
untangled the study and here's what they
found if you got a single nutrient not
much positive happened when it came to
reducing the death rate from cancer and
not too surprising vitamin C didn't do
much by itself lonus Pauling took 10,000
milligrams of Vitamin C every day for 35
years still died of cancer retinol or
vitamin A didn't work zinc riboflavin
the trace mineral mbum nin none of these
things worked as single nutrients but
one group showed significant benefit
they took three nutrients double the
American RDA I mean a pitifully low dose
double the American RDA 20 cents a
day beta carotene vitamin E and the
trace mineral selenium and they showed a
reduction in deaths from all causes by
9% this included suicide and pneumonia
and car wrecks and cancer and diabetes
and heart disease and aneurysms and
whatnot reduce deaths from all causes by
9% they reduce all cancers regardless of
the type of cancer by 133% and the type
of cancer most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and lower esophageal
cancer they're Reduce by 21% saved
almost one out of four simply by taking
in three nutrients beta carotene vitamin
E and
selenium now don't wait for your doctor
or your government to give you this
information if they haven't already
yelled at you or sent you an Urgent
health Orr or had their nurse call you
they're not going to do it I mean we're
talking this was two and a half years
ago so that you need to just take the
bull by the harms and do it
yourself now my very favorite disease
and I call it my favorite disease if you
can have such a thing as a favorite
disease is arthritis and the reason why
I like arthritis it very clearly shows
people what they can do for themselves
and once you get enough confidence in
dealing with a disease you say well gosh
maybe I can be this good working with
another one and so on and so it kind of
gives you that confidence you need to
make some decisions on your own without
having to ask a doctor for everything
now there's not a single medical
treatment designed to fix arthritis yet
75% of all Americans over the age of 50
get it to one kind or one degree or
another and according to the CDC the
Center for Disease control over the next
7 to 10 years 35 million baby boomers of
whom there's quite a few in this room
are going to get it there's not a single
medical treatment designed to fix it by
contrast in veterinary medicine we're
encouraged to find nutritional formulas
that are designed to to prevent and cure
all kinds of diseases in animals
including arthritis so the advantage my
patients had was I'm a veterinarian as
well as a physician so I went into my
Veterinary background and I took all
these Veterinary formulas designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and and
chickens turkeys and pheasants and
pigeons and dogs and cats and sheep and
pigs and horses and cows and lions and
tigers and
bears and and adapted them to human use
and I came up with what I called Dr
Wallock Pig arthritis formula not
because there's any pigs in there but
because it was used to prevent and cure
arthritis and pigs now this little
formula over the last 20 plus years I
have literally seen regrow caragen bone
in literally tens of thousands of people
right now there's over a quarter of a
million people a month using Dr wallik
Pig arthritis formula and it's going up
at a rate of 3 to 4,000 new people a
month and the reason is of course it
works now the medical profession would
differ with this they'd say now wallik
that's absolutely not true everybody
knows you can't regrow carage and Bone
when you have bone to bone arthritis the
only thing left for you medically is to
have joint replacement
surgery and I'd have to agree with them
I'd have to agree with them that if the
only raw materials you're using is
aspirin and Tylenol and gold shots and
Methotrexate and prazone and cortisone
you're not going to regrow caragen bone
because those are not the raw materials
to do it they have many many side
effects many of which are fatal when
these things over the counter and
prescription medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and these
procedures are all directed towards
relieving pain I mean it's such a
terrible painful disease that people are
willing to let surgeons cut out their
knees and their hips and their shoulders
and any attempt to relieve pain so I
came up with Dr wallik Pig arthritis
formula well Harvard medical schools
laid in the bushes for me for 25 years
and they said ha we've finally found a
way to to prove that wck is a quack and
a fraud in charlatan because everybody
knows you can't regrow caragen bone and
they took what they thought was the most
ridiculous one-third of Dr Wall's Pig
arthritis formula and they gave it to 29
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
them off all their medication wasn't do
them any good anyway and the only thing
left for them medically was joint
replacement surgery and they gave him a
heaping tablespoon full of groundup chi
chicken carage and orange juice every
morning for 90 days just three short
months and here's what happened after 10
days they had complete relief of pain
and inflammation something they hadn't
had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they
could Now open up a new pickle jar that
never had been opened without pain to
the fingers wrist elbows and shoulder in
in 90 days just three months according
to Harvard Medical School not me 28 of
the 29 were clinically cured now you'd
think they'd call me up and say Wallock
we got to apologize to you
hey next time you come to Boston come on
in we'll buy you your lobster dinner you
know because gosh even the most
ridiculous onethird of your pig
arthritis formula did some good that's
not what happened don't be too surprised
here's what the medical director the guy
who's a professor of of medicine at
havid Medical School in Baston here's
what he said quote after three months it
was clear that the drug was beneficial
unquote chicken carage had become a drug
in 90
days now why would you think that would
happen well be because you can't pay P
chicken carage so they went out to the
US Patton office and they got a used
Paton on chicken carage and you two now
for 3500 bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical Schools chicken carage in a
capsule arthritis cure 3500 bucks a
month so if this sounds a little pricey
to you all you have to do is go to
Kentucky Fried Chicken buy a $5 bucket
of chicken throw away the meat and eat
the ends off the bones it's the same
stuff now if you have several people in
your family that could get a little
pricey you know if you have arthritis so
what you want to do then is go to the
dumpster behind the KFC in the dark dark
of the
Night Take Your Kids or your grandkids
give them an empty 5 gallon feed bucket
put them in that dumpster let them scoop
out the bones for you and take them home
put those bones on a cookie sheet put
them in an oven bake them dry pound them
into a flow with your own ballpen hammer
and then fill those chicken car or you
know those capsules yourself and you
just don't want to let anybody know what
you're doing because if the word gets
out you know Francine is making chicken
carage CS she's curing everybody in the
neighborhood of arthritis the FDA is
going to come arrest you in your house
for manufacturing patented drug or worse
yet they'll send Janet to save you from
yourself and she'll burn your house
down so if you want to avoid all these
legal entanglements and you don't want
to get all those gushy chicken bones all
over your house all you have to do is go
to a good grocery store and get yourself
um some either nox gelatin or wam at
Valley gelatin unflavored unsweetened
it's the same stuff it's the condr and
sulfate in there which is the basic
building block to rebuil cartilage and
uh bone bone matrix bone Foundation if
your neck sounds like a bag full of
gravel you got low back problems loose
teeth and all those kinds of things you
want to give Dr Wall Pig arthritis
formula a try and I'll give you the full
formula at the
end another one of my favorite disease
is Alzheimer's disease it's a physician
caused disease it's pretty powerful
statement it's a physician caused
disease we didn't have Alzheimer's
disease 40 years ago was not in any
medical dictionary medical textbooks it
was not taught in any medical class it
only became a disease entity in
1979 today according to Ralph nater it
Rivals cancer and cost $300,000 per
patient and it's the number four killer
of adults over the age of 65 behind
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
then comes Alzheimer's disease now we
eliminated Alzheimer's disease from
animals from 40 years ago can you
imagine a Dairy Farmer with 400 headed
cows out in the pasture with Alzheimer's
disease and he's yelling at them you
know and rattling the feed bucket trying
to get them up to get milk and the cows
are all out there scratching their head
saying
why do we want to go to the barn to get
milk and if we did where's the barn
because he kind
of so the farmer has to put fuel in the
ATV and ride out there and HT them up
and the you know fuel cost goes up labor
cost goes up so they have to raise the
price of milk nobody's happy so we
eliminated Alzheimer's Disease by
eliminating vegetable oil corn oil and
soil from the animals diet and putting
in large doses of vitamin E and selenium
well this is one of those two-cent
photocopies you should have gotten from
your doctors 3 and a half years ago
almost four years ago now this is not
from the national
Inquirer this is from the University of
California San Diego School of Medicine
a very reputable research institution
they said vitamin E KES memory loss in
Alzheimer's patients I don't know how
many of you saw that little article and
I'm waiting to get a copy of it so I can
make another overhead just last week
from one of the English universities and
they came out and said yeah people take
in 800 units of vitamin E every day the
odds of them getting a heart attack are
Alzheimer's disease almost zero
Alzheimer's disease disease is an
American disease it does not occur in
third world countries it does not occur
in
Europe it's an American disease that's
because all our doct well I'll tell you
in a minute I'll prove it to you in a
minute that it's a physician caused
disease how many of you heard whether
you believe it or not that vegetable
oils are healthier far than a terrible
saturated animal fat whether you believe
it or not raise your hand if you've
heard it that's pretty good about 50%
the other half of you are either asleep
lying or have Alzheimer's because I know
you've heard it
now we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry that that vegetable oils
were bad for you because we tried to get
animals to gain weight faster by giving
them 20% and 40% of the ration as corn
oil or soil because it has double the
amount of calories as does crack corn
oils have nine calories per gram and
carbohydrate type calories from either
uh beet pulp or or crack corn has
something like four and a half calories
per gram and sure enough for the first
couple of weeks that animals were on the
oils they gain weight many times faster
than ones just getting carbohydrate
calories
but in 6 weeks they all died of heart
attack so we knew it was a good idea
that went bad somewhere and they said
well what do we do with this stuff no
farmer is dumb enough to give it to his
livestock anymore they look we've
contracted with Farmers to grow millions
of tons of corn oil and soil every year
for the next 50 years what do we do with
this stuff he said well it's not proven
in human beings yet that it's dangerous
let's convince people that vegetable oil
is good for them and they've done a
pretty good job over the last 35 40
years haven't they all you got to do is
go into the dairy case I mean this is
really blatant you go to the dairy case
in the grocery store and you five find
85 brands of corn oil margarine in the
dairy case that's how much they've
brainwash people you should have gotten
this information three and a half years
ago vegetable oils can cause heart
disease it's a nightmare said Dr Edward
mkin a specialist in food oils for the
US Department of Agriculture it's really
a nasty thing when you try to explain it
there's now total confusion for
consumers why would there be total
confusion for consumers well that's
because the truth is different from what
you've been taught for 35 years here's
another look at the same problem margin
can increase your risk of heart attacks
a lot of people say to me well I've got
a whole freezer full of tub margarine
can I use
that tub margarine stick margarine
doesn't matter it's the
same this was what they called the
Harvard nurses health study and they
took 990,000 nurses over 20 years
divided them into two groups put one
group on margarine as they're spread for
their crackers and bread and cooking
sharding put the other 4 5,000 nurses on
butter for their spread and their
crackers and bread and cooking
sharenting at the end of the 20 years
they looked at their death certificates
and for every hundred nurses who had
died of a heart attack 70 of them were
in the margarine group you have a two
and a half times greater risk of dying
of a heart attack if you use margarine
than butter now the biggest fraud ever
perpetuated against the American people
the biggest fraud ever perpetuated
against the American people is this
cholesterol
thing this is one of those two- Cent
photocopies you should have got from
your doctor doctors three and a half
years ago top researchers reluctantly
admit that low levels of cholesterol are
bad for you low levels of cholesterol
are worse for you than high levels of
cholesterol this is from the University
of California at San Francisco a
researcher who is renowned as the top
the top medical researcher on
cholesterol and cardiovascular disease
his name is Steven B hully here's
another look at the same study three and
a half years ago here's what he said
quote what it comes down to is there's
an extraordinary set of observations
that have emerged this year because For
the First time we have a large enough
study to really see them what he said
there was for 40 years we've been giving
you
Kaka you know stuff that's in baby
diapers and
um we didn't really know the truth about
cholesterol so we made stuff up just we
thought it was good for us so we made
stuff up but now after 20 years we
finally have the truth now why on this
God's green earth would anybody want to
have a blood cholesterol below 180
always because a doctor instructed you
or ordered you to do it
now about seven years ago actually it
was May 1st 7 years ago I began
lecturing 300 nights out of each year
like this all across the country and in
the beginning the crowds were just three
people then it was 20 and then 50 and
then 100 and for the last 5 years has
been hundreds and the interest is
growing and people doing things for
themselves and my wife said look I'll
support you out in the field if you want
to do that for S to 10 years but it's
going to you know it's going to take a
lot of of toll on you eating Hotel food
and having weird hours and driving all
night to get one place or another what I
want you to do if you're going to do
this is to have yourself a hobby and
every time you feel yourself really
getting so warped out that they're going
to come after you with a butterfly net
or a straight jacket study this Hobby
and get yourself calmed down before you
get in front of an audience well that's
good advice I'll do that but after the
hundreds of different things I looked at
I settled on collecting obituaries of
medical
doctors as my hobby now the reason was
of course it's a very useful piece of
information if doctors knew what they
were talking about when it came to
Health and Longevity
if you separate them out from the rest
of the American population they should
be healthier and live longer than
anybody else and boy was I surprised I
started out a 100 years ago June 15th
1895 in jamama which is the Premier
Medical journal in the world actually
Journal American Medical Association and
they did a survey a hundred years ago on
deaths in American doctors what they
found out the average lifespan of
medical doctors 100 years ago was
54.6 54.6 the average population in
America the average lifespan was 62
now they were in trouble then 100 years
later January of 1993 I redid the study
using obituaries from the journal
American Medical Association just like
they did originally and guess what the
average lifespan for medical doctors
today is 57.6 I gave them the benefit of
the doubt and rounded it up to 58 the
average lifespan for the average
American is 75.5 he gained almost 20
years statistically by not going to
medical
school so I brought you a few of my
favorites so you can see what fun I'm
having and of course all of these are
Physicians who have died of nutritional
deficiency diseases um Stuart cartright
age 38 was a family practitioner
good-look kid I'm sure he could have
been a movie actor if he wanted to I
promise you he married the prom queen
and uh he probably had a Mercedes
convertible in Southern California
probably never repaid a student loan all
the things that medical students put on
their list of of wishes and he dropped
dead in his home from a ruptured
coronary artery
aneurysm and the fascinating thing to me
is this is something we learned in
turkeys in the 50s 1957 how to prevent
and in the early stages reverse
aneurysms and of course this was from a
study at 250,000 turkeys the USDA put on
a complete turkey pellet trying to get
these turkeys to finish for Market
within a week or two of each other as
opposed to strung on all over the whole
summer when they're on pasture and in
the first 13 weeks fully half of them
125,000 of them died farmers were out
there every morning picking them up with
a bushel basket full took them into the
state Diagnostic lab to see what they
died from and when they cut them open at
autopsy every one of them had died of a
ruptured a Artic aneurysm and one of the
clever pathologist says Ah that's got to
be due to a copper deficiency because
everybody knows that the elastic fibers
and arteries and skin and other tissues
require a large amount of copper to be
manufactured and the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on the weakened wall of a
tire you know when you hit a Chuck hole
and you break the cords in a tire the
internal pressure on the tire blows a
balloon and you thump down the highway
and heat it up it'll blow same way with
an aneurysm when you get a breakdown of
those elastic fibers the internal
pressure in an artery even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon it's called
an aneurysm and if it ruptures you bleed
to death so they got excited about this
they doubled the amount of copper in
those pellets the next year they tried
to raise 500,000 turkeys and they did
not lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss simply by adding a little copper
and they got all excited about this and
they started looking at Copper deficient
diets and copper levels and human blood
and tissues and what they came up with
was this the very first symptom of
copper deficiency in human beings is
white gray or silver hair I see a lot of
copper deficiency in this room tonight
okay and of course you don't want to be
like a medical doctor and just color
your hair because you know that's
treating the symptom but not obviously
getting down to the root cause of things
and if you don't take action at this
point and uh don't give yourself some of
the right type of copper what's going to
happen is you start getting a breakdown
of the elastic fibers in your skin and
you get crows feet around the corners of
your eyes and your mouth parts of your
Anatomy begin to Sag and you know you're
in trouble when you go to your doctor
and he says you know I've got a golf
buddy down the hall who's a plastic
surgeon for $10,000 he'll make you look
20 years younger but you don't need a
booby lift a tummy tuck or dairy Air
Lift or a facial lift all you need is
some colloidal copper and everything
will come back up just like you have a
hydraulic jack under
it now if you don't take action at that
point you got to break down the elastic
fibers and the large veins of your legs
and you get varicose veins you don't
take action at this point you get to
break down the elastic fibers and the
large veins of your exhaust pipe and you
get hemorrhoids so if you if you have
hemorrhoids varicose veins things that
sag wrinkles white gray or silver hair
the odds already have aneurysms
developing in you somewhere and don't be
like old frank who dies suddenly of a
ruptured aneurysm and all his friends
get together at Denny's after the
funeral and eating some of that famous
blueberry cheesecake and they say we
never thought Frank would be the first
one to go I mean he was Mr Fitness this
guy walked five miles before breakfast
every morning he ripped the chicken skin
off the chicken before he ate it took an
aspirin every day he went to the health
club every night and did those water
aerobics with the young people and he
always look so distinguished in his gray
hair his body had been screaming at him
for 25 years Frank give me some copper
Frank give me some copper he just stood
in the mirror and said man I look like
Einstein you know my gray hair what did
Einstein die from a ruptured a Arctic
aneurism what color was Einstein's hair
Snow White now this fellow here Dr
Michael Pete RZ 38 years old also 20
years before the average for Physicians
and 40 years before the average American
he was a jogger Dr Michael prz was a
jogger 38 years old and he encouraged
his well patients to jog with him he
gave him a 10% discount on his Services
if they would jog with him a minimum of
15 days out of each month so he had this
big groupy thing every day that all
these patients were jogging with him
because they wanted this 10% discount in
the
services well he collapsed and died in
front of his horrified patients while
they were jogging
of a simple cardiopathy heart attack a
selenium deficiency and because they
didn't want to give up that 10% discount
on the services they all kept jogging
nobody stopped to give them any
[Music]
CPR Dr Martin Carter age 57 one year
before the average for Physicians and 20
years before the average American was an
expert according to the New York Times
obituaries this guy had every drop of
medical education you yet in the whole
world but he didn't have expensive urine
he didn't have expensive urine even
though his mom and dad were proud of him
the cause of death was a ruptured atic
aneurysm just like those copper
deficient turkeys this is my mother's
favorite obituary she found it I have to
use it all the time keep mom
happy this was what two almost three
years ago now July of 93 Dr Gail Clark
age 47 was the chief cardiologist at her
hospital she's walking down the halls of
her hospital with a stethoscope around
her neck she drops dead and let's say
you're a heart patient in the ICU and
your monitor shows your stable beep beep
beep beep and then you hear them you
know they Clos the curtain next to you
you don't know it's your doctor being
brought in there you hear them cut the
clothes off and they're yelling for the
code carts and the paddles and contact
gel and they need some bicarbon some um
epinephrine and that sort of thing and
then you hear them say Okay clear
everybody here we go
contact didn't work okay we need some
turn the paddles up more gel more
contact gel clear clear here we go
then they turn on the
monitor flat line so you know she's dead
we say nurse now your monitor is going
because you're nervous say nurse nurse
what what on next door sounded awful
with all the screaming and code cards
and then says you know your cardiologist
the chief cardiologist of this Hospital
Dr Gail Clark age 47 just cro next door
from a cardiopathy heart attack a simple
selenium deficiency disease you see all
the patients holding their gowns and
they're running out of the hospital as
fast as they can go because whatever the
chief got they don't want I mean if it
kills the chief and you don't why would
you want
it Dr George Kohler the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
he was in the 20th century Dr George
Kohler 37 years old wins the Nobel Prize
and medicine for his uh work with
antibodies monoclonal antibodies he's
going to save people from cancer which
is a righteous type of research 11 years
later age
48 boom drops dead from a cardiopathy
heart attack a simple selenium
efficiency disease because he believed
you could get everything you needed from
your four food
groups remember I told you when I came
back from
Africa I was supposed to find an early
warning system and it turned out that
the early warning system is not a wombat
or a koala bear a ruby throated
hummingbird or a rare and endangered
fish or reptile turns out that our early
warning system is our own young athletes
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control 100,000 young athletes
under the age of 30 drop dead each year
during exercise or a game or immediately
after exercise or a game 100,000 double
the number who were killed in car
accidents 10 years ago I began to see
articles like this in medical journals
sudden death in young athletes and this
is a small study but it gives you a
flavor of what's going on here 29 highly
conditioned competitive athletes ages 13
to 30 drop dead during a game in this
study 35% of them died of ruptured
aneurysms a copper deficiency the other
65% Di of cardiomyopathy heart disease a
selenium deficiency now what do you
think is the most dangerous sport in the
world you can yell them out to me boxing
basketball
hockey football
jogging cross country racing it turns
out that it is
basketball
45% or 45,000 out of the
100,000 are basketball players and I'll
show you why in a minute football
happens to be
second here are some of the faces of the
Young Americans these are you know the
the the pride of America these are kids
who are healthy apparently and just
suddenly Dro dead during games 14 15 16
18 years
old here's a water polo player 14 years
old cardiomyopathy heart
disease 15 years old Stanley
Hawkins freshman in high
school just practicing basketball drops
over dead from a cardiopathy heart
attack selenium
deficiency Darren mot 22 years old 6'5
had just signed a multi-million dollar
contract with an NBA
team just shooting some baskets and it
wasn't even a game he was in his jeans's
T-shirt just shooting some baskets went
for a layup put the ball in the basket
came down he was dead par him out with
the heart attack selenium deficiency
here's one that's a little more famous
Reggie
Lewis 27-year-old captain of the Boston
Celtics April of 1993 a little over
three years ago
now collapsed during a playoff game with
the Charlotte Hornets and was diagnosed
very accurately and very quickly as
having cardiopathy heart disease and
because he was a $65 million contract
athlete the Celtics hired the top 12
cardiologists in the whole world and
referred to this collection of doctors
which they accumulated in Boston as the
dream team of cardiologists they called
him the dream team of cardiologists gave
him a million bucks each to refer all
their Pat out to other doctors and lo
and
behold lo and behold um they were
supposed to devote their full time to
saving Reggie they didn't take 50 bucks
of their money and give it to a medical
student or Premed student to go to the
medical library and and like Star Trek
ask the computer computer what are all
the known causes of cardiopathy if they
would have done that the computer would
have said there's only one known cause
of cardiopathy it was discovered in
animals in 1957 and the disease was
eliminated from animals in 1958 it was
proven in human beings in 1972 with a
double blind crossover study with 45,000
human subjects and the disease was
eliminated in the country in which this
was
done the only known cause of
cardiomyopathy heart disease in both
animals and human beings is a deficiency
of the trace mineral selenium they
didn't do that and as a result they
didn't give Reggie Lewis 10 cents a day
worth of selenium if they would have
done that Reggie Lewis would still be
alive today and as a result while they
were bickering 3 months after his
initial heart attack Reggie Lewis 27
years old July 28th 1993 dies of a
second cardiomyopathy heart attack now
if the dream team of cardiologist
wouldn't give a $65 million athlete 10
cents a day worth of selenium what's the
chances of your cardiologist giving you
any well watch my lips if you haven't
gotten it by now
none okay I think you get the picture
now if you wait long enough if you wait
long enough justice has a way of coming
around doesn't it you know my hobby so
you shouldn't be too surp surprised that
a year and a half after Reggie Lewis
died the chief of the dream team of
cardiologists one Dr W Thomas Nessa a
marathon runner finished the Boston
Marathon three times before he died was
the vice chairman of the Department of
Cardiology at havit Medical School age
48 boom drops dead from a cardiopathy
heart attack Dr W Thomas Ness a member
of the dream team of
cardiologists who treated the late
Boston Celtics Captain Reggie Lewis died
in his own home of the same thing I mean
this guy had to be malignant
dumb right I mean he didn't learn
anything from a $65 million autopsy
November 1995 Sergey Groff two-time Gold
Medal winner of Paris figure skating
1988 1994 in the Olympic Games was just
tying of skates was just tying of skates
at Lake plet New York getting ready to
get into Peak uh physical condition for
his upcoming Olympics drops over dead
age 28 from cardiomyopathy heart attack
just like Reggie Lewis age 27
[Applause]
here's one Matt laaa backup uh pitcher
San Diego Padres 20 years old collapsed
and died from cardiopathy heart
attack here's a good
story Evander Holyfield Evander
Holyfield was banned almost three years
ago now from boxing because he developed
cardiopathy heart disease not the sudden
type that kills you instantly but slow
wasting in the heart muscle kind of a
muscular distrophy of the heart muscle
he was banned from boxing because he
couldn't pass the physical anymore about
7 months into his retirement I ran into
one of his physicians in a seminar like
this in Atlanta we talked about the
relationship between selenium deficiency
and cardiomyopathy heart disease and
they began to give Vander Holyfield some
selenium 10 months later his
electrocardiogram goes to normal and he
passes the physical for the boxing
commission something that never happens
people with cardiopathy heart disease
never go back to normal but then all
they get is pacemakers and heart trans
trans plants so any rate he passes the
physical he boxes about a year ago wins
his first fight back in the ring three
months later he passes a physical again
loses the fight but then about I don't
know 6 eight weeks ago passes a physical
again four weeks ago he fought again and
won the fight and he's going strong now
simply because he took some minerals
here selenium if you get into this
situation don't let your doctor tell you
you only have two choices either cavor
in or the heart transplant
you have a third choice and now you're
informed about this so you can make that
decision on your
own the rate of brain cancer in America
has gone up 400% in the last 40 years
and everybody's pointing their fingers
towards cellular telephones and
everybody's trying to give me a cellular
telephone so I started examining this
was there anything to that and you don't
have to worry about it if you use them
because 97% of the people who use
cellular telephone or excuse me 97% of
the people with brain cancer have never
even been in the same room with a
cellular telephone let alone use one so
you don't have to worry about that but
there is a little known Trace mineral
known as gallium this Trace mineral
gallium g l l i m when you give it to
laboratory animals in optimal amounts
and then you give them a chemical known
to cause brain cancer they don't get it
if you give them a laboratory
experimental diet that's deficient in
gallium and then give them that same
chemical they all get brain cancer so I
believe there's huge increase in in rate
of brain cancer in America is a
combination of a gallium deficiency and
a lot of chemicals in our air water and
food that do cause brain cancer think
about all the performers who die
suddenly um who whose performances are
almost athletic in their presentation
people like Elvis He died of cardiopathy
heart disease and because he had lots of
drugs in his blood and his liver they
blamed his death on the drugs but he
really died of cardiomyopathy heart
disease which is a selenium deficiency
disease then you look at Conway Twitty
who died in front of 3,000 fans in
Branson Missouri with a ruptured a Artic
aneurysm a copper
efficiency you look at Michael Jackson
collapsed in December of 1995 and was in
the Intensive Care Unit for one week
because his blood minerals and
electrolytes were all messed up almost
died when you go to a basketball game a
football game a track meat look out
there at those well-trained athletes the
odds are all the couch potatoes and the
stands and bleachers have a much better
chance of living to be over 80 than
those athletes do and here I'll put out
my challenge if you can find me an
obituary of any University semi Pro or
pro
athlete who's lived to be over hundred
I'll give you a $100
bill because I've looked real hard the
average lifespan for athletes both
University and Semi-Pro and professional
is 62 to 65 depending on their sport
Here's the final clue as many as 62% of
the female college gymnast suffer from
anorexia they suffer from anorexia 62%
is that because it's genetic no is that
because all their mothers hate them no
is that because they think they're too
fat absolutely not I used to see a lot
of these gals in the 70s and ' 80s when
I practiced up in Portland argum because
that was the time of Olga Corbett and
you may remember her as being the
darling of the world because um um she'd
won every gymnastic event in the
Olympics and the same Olympiad with a
perfect score and everybody wanted their
little girl to be at Olga Corbett and I
used to see them they'd get split lips
and fractured and dislocations because
they you know they were weren't all
perfect and they'd hit those bars going
full speed and and get dislocations and
split lips and twist and sprains and
strains and bruises but the ones that
fascinated me were the little 8 10 12
years old that were depressed and
anorexic certainly not typical of a
teenage girl or pre-teen girl and so I
used to do hair analysis on them because
that was the only way I could
communicate with them because they
weren't sociable they wouldn't eat they
didn't want to U um study or they didn't
want to do their um Athletics anymore
and sure enough every one of them were
severely deficient in many many
nutrients 30 40 nutrients but all of
them were uniformly severely deficient
in two trait minerals zinc and lithium
zinc and lithium so I began to give them
as many as 25 or 30 nutrients
intravenously two or three times a week
paying special attention to giving them
lots of zinc and lithium and sure enough
in 14 to 21 days they were eating like
little pigs again they were real
interested in going out and and training
they were sociable again and all the
parents who took their little girls who
were anorexic to counselors and shrinks
those little girls were counseled unto
death now you may remember Karen
Carpenter from the singing group The
brother sister the carpenter ERS she was
30 years old give her take a year or so
she developed anorex and because they
had lots of money they went around the
world and went to all the shrinks and
and the counselors in Moscow and Berlin
and London and Paris all over the United
States and they counseled her unto death
because you cannot counsel somebody well
who has a terminal zinc deficiency you
have to give him some
zinc now what possibly could be the
common denominator between a 65lb
gymnast a 7 foot tall basketball player
250lb boxer boxing champion and these
Runners that have less than 4% body fat
on them what could possibly be the
common
denominator they all sweat and when you
sweat you sweat out all 60 essential
nutrients all 60 essential minerals you
don't just sweat out you don't just
sweat out potassium and Gatorade you
sweat out all 60 essential minerals and
when you sweat out all of your selenium
and don't replace it by
supplementation on the average you're
going to get a cardiopathy heart attack
you sweat out all of your copper and
don't replace it by supplementation
you're going to get an aneurysm you
sweat out all of your chromium and
vadium you're going to get diabetes you
sweat out all of your gallium and don't
replace it you're going to get a brain
cancer if you're a teenage girl and you
sweat out all of your zinc and your
lithium you're going to get
anorexia get the picture now the reason
why athletes are early warning system as
a rule they sweat out more in 20 to 30
years and a couch potato does in 80
years they've compressed a whole
lifetime of sweating into 20 years
that's why there are early warning
system now you don't have to be an
athlete to sweat though let's say you're
a postmenopausal woman and you have
night sweats let's say you're a welder
or a farmer a carpenter let's say you
work in the oven room of a Pizza Hut any
place that you sweat even if you work in
a an office situation where you have an
air conditioned office and you just use
a keyboard and you never get one beat of
sweat on you I mean you can go a whole
week wear the same clothes nobody will
know
right but then you go out every night
and you do aerobics or you jog and you
sweat then so it doesn't matter why you
sweat whether it's for recreation or at
work if you don't replace those minerals
you're in line you're putting yourself
at high high risk developing a lot of
these degenerative diseases many of
which are debilitating and certainly
many of which are
fatal what's the very first symptom of
mineral deficiencies in animals and
people it's called paa and cribbing
Farmers know about this when they see an
animal chewing on The Hitching Post and
these are a couple Amish horses up in
Lancaster County Pennsylvania when they
see them chew chewing on The Hitching
Post the fence rails things like shovel
handles the half doors on the barn the
the door jams on the barn a good farmer
recognizes this as an animal that's in
trouble though they they are minerally
deficient how many of you either are or
know of a chocaholic raise your hand
yeah that's the munchies that's Pik and
cribbing that's a mineral deficiency
it's the only thing will cause that how
many of you know of a coholic or or a
Pepsi holic raise your hand yeah a day
without 12 Pepsis I can't function okay
these are minerally defic efficient
people and that's one of the reasons why
we have a weight challenge in America
because people have been taught to put
calories in their mouth instead of
minerals there's no calories in minerals
next time you have these terrible
Cravings instead of putting chips and
dips and chocolate and donuts in your
mouth try some minerals you'll not only
lose weight but you'll feel better and
live
longer my favorite mineral is lithium
the reason why I like lithium is shrinks
think it's a drug that only they can
prescribe when in fact is one of those
60 essential minerals that everybody
needs every day and like all essential
nutrients if it's missing if it's
missing for um six months 9 months 12
months a year or so you get on the
average 10 deficiency diseases which
include depression manic depression
bipolar disease suicidal Behavior
violent Behavior Uh spouse abuse child
abuse domestic violence drug addictions
alcohol addictions these are all
symptoms of lithium deficiency and
people who've been challenged with sugar
natural or processed we'll talk more
about that in a minute I believe we
should be putting lithium in our
drinking water because first of all it's
safer than chlorine and Florine and
number two we could eliminate 85% of all
domestic violence if we would just put
lithium in our drinking
water now you can pick up and diagnose a
child with lithium deficiency and one
who's in trouble by looking at their
coloring
projects if you look at their coloring
projects if they're deficient in lithium
and are sensitive to Sugar we'll talk
about that in a second um these are kids
who are going to take a dark color black
brown purple dark red dark blue dark
green and scribble all over the page
with little or no intent to stay in the
lines these are kids who are in
trouble you can project these four fivey
olds are going to drop out of high
school they're not going to learn how to
write read or do math uh they're going
to have a lousy personal life they're
never going to be happy during a
marriage they're going to be violent
types and so forth these are kids who
are in trouble they're going to
experiment with cigarettes and alcohol
and drugs but they're salvageable
because this is the same kid here 6
weeks later simply getting him off of
sugar natural and processed no apple
juice no grape juice no honey no
molasses no Pepsis no um chocolate no
ding-dongs no sugar Frosted Flakes and
that sort of thing and um supplemented
them this kid with lithium chromium and
vadium look at the heels on the boots
and the boots the glove the uniform
sleeve the glove the border on the
foot and the border on the hat and so
forth all in the lines the tail and so
on and with more appropriate color
you can save these kids if you just pay
attention it's not they don't just have
an art aptitude they're in trouble okay
now if these kids also wet the bed far
after they're supposed to be potty
training they're 6 8 10 12 14 years old
and they wet the bed um they have a
history of scribbling all over the page
without staying in the lines they are
cruel to little animals and other kids
and they love to play with matches and
fire these are kids who if you don't
save them at this early age you can
project they're going to become mass
murders and serial killers it just
happens that
way here's what happens next you start
getting kids with what's called
Geographic tongues Geographic tongues
are red pulpy and painful they have
ulcers and erosions all over their
tongues these kids have zero brain waves
they can't learn how to read right and
do math uh if you don't take care of
them there they're going to drop out of
school and experiment with cigarettes
alcohol and drugs when they hit 12 14 16
years old look at the allergic shiners
under this kid's eyes this is not
physical abuse he's just sensitive to
sugar and people are sens to Sugar just
like some people are sensitive to
alcohol you know there's a good
alcoholic a person who will drink a beer
and a shot of whiskey they'll go to
sleep these are quote good alcoholics
there's people who drink a beer maybe
have a shot of whiskey and they get
boisterous and obnoxious and they start
singing loud songs and being loud and
they think jokes are funny that aren't
funny and then you get people who drink
and they just get mean and um uh become
downright dangerous to themselves and
everybody else the same thing is true
with sugar there's some people who take
in sugar and they get low blood sugar
and they just go to sleep some people
who get uh take in Sugar they get Rowdy
and attention deficit disorder ADHD
hyperactivity learning disabilities and
they get kind of obnoxious and then
there are people who take in sugar and
they become serial killers and they get
violent and so people are sensitive to
Sugar just like they are to alcohol and
you get them off of sugar natural and
processed and supplement them with
lithium chromium and vadium you can save
them and everybody around them here's a
20-year-old you don't need to be a
clinical psychologist to see that he's
depressed look at the allergic shiners
under his eyes and these are the type of
kids who live on Pepsis and ding-dongs
their whole life they're quiet they stay
in their rooms they with their headsets
and they listen to their music or they
might play on the keyboards or their
computers and then one day when grandma
gives them an irritation of about a 0.1
on the scale of 1 to 10 you got to do
the dishes before I give you the car
keys they'll walk into the kitchen pick
up the Cleaver and smack Grandma's head
off they'll respond with a 10 right and
they're just irritated
0.1 now this is all too common right now
experts say that 30% of All American
teenagers are going to appear in
juvenile court in 1996 one-third of All
American
teenagers any rate it's a terrible
tragedy but these things do go on all
the time and uh back I guess it was the
third week in in January of this year
1996 was up in Moses Lake Washington on
a Monday night actually giving a seminar
like this and when I got to this point
guys in the front row said doc you don't
have to talk about teen violence in
Moses Lake I mean there's more people in
this uh National Guard Armory than there
is in the whole town and we only have a
couple hundred teenagers and they all
know each other by first name it's kind
of like a big family and they didn't
believe they had any teen problems in
Moses Lake well that was Monday night
Friday at 2: in the afternoon an honor
student in junior high school walks in
with his deer rifle blows away the math
teacher and two of his fellow students
now this kid was not on drugs he was not
a member of any gang there's no drugs
and gangs in Moses Lake Washington you
know the answer to why this happened I'm
going to bring it out of you what time
of the year is there more domestic
violence depression and suicide than any
other time of year Christmas holidays a
week before Christmas Christmas the time
between Christmas and New Year's from
New Years until now Super Bowl day in
fact Super Bowl day has the largest
number of violent incidents in any other
day of the year Super Bowl
day what happens during these holidays
that happens more than any other time of
year sugar I heard people say it sugar
you get more cake more pie more candy
more cookies more punch more colas and
drinks of various kinds than you get any
other time of year it's not just on
Sunday afternoon I mean we're talking
four times a day in school after school
in the evening four times or 10 times on
the weekend because it's party time
during the holidays and as a result the
people who are sensitive to sugar and
are going to get violent or depressed
come out during this time especially if
they're deficient in lithium chromium
and
vadian attention deficit disorder
another one of those Physicians cause
disease because Physicians say sugar is
okay it's better to have Ridin than
sugar you can have both you know if
you're good you can have sugar and
Ridin well if you take someone who has
ADD or ADHD tension deficit disorder or
tension deficit hyperactivity disorder
regardless of age whether they're two or
six or eight or 15 or 25 or 40 and take
them off of all sugar natural and
process and supplement them with all 90
nutrients paying special attention to
make sure that they get lithium chromium
and vadium 98% % I can't use the Cure
word but 98% will get 100% better now
the whole family has to do the same
thing you can't be guzzling Cokes and
eating donuts and expect a six-year-old
or 18-year-old to give it up the whole
family has to change and eat the same
way for the benefit not only of that
child but for the whole family because
if something goes wrong the whole family
is in
trouble now this little gal here 300
years ago would have been a vampire or a
werewolf and her own villagers would
have burned her to death at the stake
maybe the village Elders would have
killed her by driving a wooden steak
through her heart you may remember her
as Susan Smith the mother who drowned
her two sons from Union South
Carolina and we learned a lot about her
during her trial number one she tried to
commit suicide twice during High
School a lithium and chromium deficiency
nobody said to her Susan give up all
sugar natural and process we're going to
give you some lithium chromium and
vadium they didn't even give her any
Prozac all they did was give her a hug
and say Susan everybody loves you and if
you get depressed again let everybody
know and we'll talk you out of this
suicide thing two years after graduating
high school she went further into her
depression they diagnosed her as being a
manic depressive and they put her on
Prozac at that time nobody took her off
of sugar and supplemented her with any
lithium chromium and vadium and two
years later when her boyfriend realized
how wacky she was at that time tried to
disengage and break off from her and he
used the kids as a foil purposely
because most single mothers when put to
the test you have to give up your kids
if you want me to stay with you cuz you
know I'm not big enough to handle these
kids kids every time I look at those
kids I see another man he says you got
to give up those kids and most women
would say well you're out of here you
bum I'm not going to give up my kids if
you don't take the package deal you
don't get anything but she didn't do
that the night before she drowned those
two boys she went from telephone to
telephone pay telephone to pay telephone
in the parking lots of the 7-Elevens in
Union South Carolina
and she tried to call this guy because
she figured out a way to make everybody
happy she remembered a little incident
that happened to her when she was six
years old and it goes like this when she
was six years old she had six kittens
and she wanted to keep them all she
loved them all but her daddy said hey we
can only afford to take care of two so
you got to give up four and he took four
of them out of her arms and put them
into a sack with a brick and tied the
sack and threw them into a pond drowned
them he said now that was painless
didn't hurt those kittens and they're
happy because they're in heaven with God
and God's happy because those kittens
are with him and you're happy because
you get to keep two instead of none and
I'm happy because I don't have to feed
six I only have to feed two and she
remembered that story and she said well
I can make everybody happy here I'll
just drown those two boys and it'll be
painless and they'll be happy because
they'll be in heaven with God and God
will be happy because they're in heaven
with them and I'll be happy because I
get my boyfriend and he'll be happy
because he gets me without the
kids nobody took her off of any sugar
natural processor supplemented her with
any lithium chromium or vadium one more
tragic story here and then we'll get
into the summary slides and then we'll
open up for questions see if there's any
health challenges you want to talk about
this kid here I could have picked out
from his coloring projects when he was
four years old guaranteed we call him
the Wily Wonka serial killer how many of
you have ever seen the movie Wily Wonka
and the and the Chocolate Factory raise
your hand yeah pretty fun little movie
we call him the Wily Wonka serial killer
when he was four years old he was caught
on the on the shoulder of a little State
Highway in Indiana HH eating roadkills
like hard taco shells I mean we used to
call these things sail caps they were
run over so many times they were dry you
use them like frisbees right
talk about paa and cribbing I mean he
was eating roadkills at age four when he
was seven years old he was thought to be
part of a satanic cult because he was
twisting the heads off his neighbors
chickens and nailing them to the door
jams cutting the heads off their dogs
and cats putting them on Pikes and
planting them in front of their yard
cruelty to little animals he wet the bed
until he was 12 years old when he was 13
years old he was a full-blown alcoholic
he'd sit in class and drink beer cans
and crunch them and disrupt the class
but his teachers were terrified to kick
him out of C class because he threatened
to burn their house down he loved to
play with
fire all right now because he was such a
threatening kid they gave him straight A
and graduated him a year early out of
high school moved him right along he
then joined the army and became a medic
because he had such good grades they
made him a medic and encouraged him to
apply to medical school the only reason
he did not get into medical school was
he was being treated as an alcoholic in
the Army he said hey you dry out apply
to medical school again we'll take
you well after 3 years the the Army
kicked him out as being a hopeless
alcoholic he moved up to Milwaukee and
lived with his grandmother and he worked
in a chocolate factory for four years
and he ate chocolate for breakfast lunch
and supper because it was free to
employees he used his minimum wage
paycheck to buy alcohol and drugs at
night and in four years when that
chocolate didn't hold this horrible
craving he had anymore he killed
dismembered in eight parts of 17 human
beings Jeffrey
dmer nobody told him anywhere along his
life to give up sugar and supplement
with lithium chromium and vadium all
they did was say now Jeffrey it's not
nice to kill this member and eat
people we require 90 essential nutrients
60 minerals 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and fortunately
for the thousands of years we've been
around we haven't had to think about
this too much as human beings because
our food plants are grains fruits
vegetables and nuts take carbon dioxide
from the air and manufacture long carbon
chains long car carbon chains and many
of these long carbon chains are vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids and this is
where this myth came from you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups because plants do manufacture a
certain amount of vitamins amino acids
and fatty acids but we've tried this
experiment for a 100 years or 200 years
and we've learned if you eat the four
food groups and don't supplement you can
live to be an average of 75.5 about half
of what we're genetically capable
of so I sat down one day and I said well
how much of of these grains fruits and
vegetables and nuts you have to eat
every day to live to be over 100 and I
calculate you need six cups each of 15
different plant groups grains fruits
vegetables and nuts to get enough
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids to
live to be over 100 that's 90 cups a day
it's a full bushel you have two problems
if you want to do that number one you
have a capacity problem if anybody in
this room can eat a bushel of anything
I'll give you a $100 bill number two if
you eat a bushel of fruits and
vegetables every day guess where you're
going to spend most of your life
you guessed it you're going to be on
that little house pot you know going
through about 10 rolls of charman a
day you'll only be able to work with a
laptop computer and a cellular telephone
because you're not going to not going to
be able to go anywhere else so even
though it is thetically possible to get
all the vitamins and amino acids and
fatty acids you need from eating your
four food groups you can only expect to
get 75.5 give or take sometimes 80 years
sometimes 65 years but on the average
75.5 if you want to live to be over 100
and be healthful you have to take in
supplements of vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids now minerals are a different
story plants cannot manufacture minerals
the only minerals that you find in
plants are those that are in the soil in
which they're grown plants will take up
minerals out of the soil and the reason
why we're in trouble in America is for
the last 100 years we've used a simple
fertilizer NPK nitrogen phosphorus
potassium we did on our farm people
still do today and they will for the
next Thousand Years use the simple
fertilizer NPK because it gives the
farmer the maximum yield in terms of
tons and bushels per acre farmers are
paid for tons and bushels nobody gives a
farmer any type of tax incentive or cash
incentive to make sure that you get all
60 essential minerals that's your
responsibility Farmers Only generate
tons and bushels per acre that's what
they do and they do a very good job we
know that it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the nutritional minerals out of
our farm soils and we've been using NPK
for 100 years so you know you don't have
to be a rocket science just to figure
out that there's a deficit there US
Senate document 264 says there's no
longer any nutritional minerals left in
our farm and Rain soils and as a result
the crops that are grown there are
minerally deficient as a result the
animals and people who eat these
minerally deficient crops get mineral
deficiency diseases and the only way to
prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplementation that's US Senate
document
264 now to me the scary thing about US
Senate document 264 is it was written
and published by the US Senate in 1936
60 years ago this information was known
60 years
ago this is not yesterday's news it's 60
years old this is the time at which we
began to put vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals into animal feeds to make
up the deficit
unfortunately unfortunately for human
beings we got Wonder drugs at the same
time we got sulfa drugs in 1936 we got
penicillin in 38 cortisone in 42 and
everybody was led to believe if we give
medical research enough money and enough
time they'll find a wonder drug to fix
everything everything you just need to
eat your four food groups and run around
willy-nilly and everything will be all
right one of the studies that fascinated
me in Rio in 1992 at the Earth Summit
was this study here where they compared
the amount of minerals in our farm and
Rain cells compared to what was in there
100 years ago African Farm CS are 74%
depleted Asian Farm CS are 76% depleted
European Farm CS are 72% depleted South
America 76% the United States and Canada
and North America is 85% depleted we're
10 to 15% worse off than anybody else
and of course the reason is we had the
Marshall Plan after the second world war
for 40 years we fed the world more tons
and bushels they thought humanly
possible to grow per acre and all we put
back in the soil was NPK NPK then there
were 16 years of the Russian wheat deals
and all I put back in the soil was NPK
NPK that's why our soils are
depleted now if I haven't gotten your
attention yet I want to show you this
map this is an overlay map of the
Continental un States the black areas
have absolutely no selenium in it and
the dark gray areas is so irregular that
you wouldn't want to bet your life on
what may or may not be in
there so if you go to to a farmers's
market on the weekend or you have your
own garden what's the chances of you
having enough selenium in your food to
live to be 100 without supplementation
zero every farmer knows about this and
they put it in their animal
feeds you think animals just need it not
people
okay let's look at two minerals before
we wind it
up let's look at calcium the number one
mineral in the body your body contains
more calcium than any other
mineral 147 different diseases if you're
deficient in calcium I'm just going to
go over the top 10 with you osteoporosis
everybody knows about that today it's
the number 10 killer of adults over the
age of 65 remember 75% don't live 90
days you get complications from those
fractures it's a horrible disease in
terms of human misery in dollar spent
$335,000 to have a hip replac get them
both replaced at
$70,000 if that's uncomplicated if it's
complicated and have all kinds of
problems it might be $100,000
$200,000 now as a terrible disease as
osteoporosis is in human beings we don't
have osteoporosis and animals that's
because Farmers have a lot of common
sense let's say a farmer out here has a
100 head of cattle on his pasture and no
Cales this year calls a vet out and he
says hey Doc I'm in trouble I I haven't
had any calves this year can't repay the
operating loan I lost of money says do I
get rid of this herd and vet will come
out and examine the cows he says no the
cows are all okay but that bull up in
that shed up there has osteoporosis both
hips had so much pain couldn't breed the
cows that's why I don't have any calves
he says as a
result as a result he said um what I
want you to do is give me $70,000 I give
that bull two new hips and next year
he'll have some
calves now a farmer being very practical
he say now stand over here Doc and he
whips out his deer rifle and boom blow
blows away the bull and well the kids
are cutting the bull up into hamburger
and roast and steaks the farm is in a
dock for $70,000 I can get a new bull
every year for 70 years I I'm going to
spend that kind of money in that old
bull but every once in a while we get
one we'd like to keep because he throws
good calvs can we prevent this
osteoporosis thing and the V will say
well sure you want to prevent it all you
got to do is take 10 cents every day in
the pellets worth of calcium 10 cents
worth the calcium every day and the
pellets of those Cals when you wean them
off the cow and you won't get
osteoprosis and the farmer says no wait
a minute we can prevent a 70,000 to
$100,000 vet bill simply with 10 cents a
day worth of calcium he says yep the
farmer says well since I don't have Blue
Cross Blue Shield major medical
hospitalization Medicare Medicaid or
Hillary to watch out for those calvs I
got to pay for this out of my own pocket
he I'm going to do the 10 cent a day
calcium thing that's why we don't have
osteoporosis in animals receding gums
dentist and dental hygienist will tell
you to floss and brush after every meal
if you believe that receding gums can be
prevented or cured by flossing and
brushing I have some oceanfront property
in Idaho I'd like to sell you because
you're an easy sell now as a
veterinarian I've literally seen
hundreds of thousands of animals rats
mice rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
cows lions and tigers and bears and they
don't floss and they don't get receding
gums now they do get funky
breath CU they don't floss but they
don't get receding gums now the reason
why we don't get receding gums in
animals is because we've dealt with the
osteoporosis thing if you have receding
gums regardless of your age whether
you're 12 15 20 25 30 40 50 60 70 80
doesn't matter if you have receding gums
loose teeth gingivitis pyara
parodontitis Bridges or plates you have
osteoporosis of the face or jawbones you
see this 20 to 50 years before you can
recognize osteoporosis in the large
bones of your arms legs hips pelvis and
vertebrae so if you have any of these
problems you have osteoporosis of the
face and jaw bones
arthritis 8 % of all arthritis is wear
and tear arthritis 85% of all arthritis
is wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
anking spondilitis and of course um this
is the type of arthritis that can be
prevented and you might get 100% better
if you use Dr wallik Pig arthritis
formula which is made up out of a liquid
multiple it's made up out of a liquid
multiple plant derived that has 72
colloidal minerals in we'll talk about
collidal minerals in just a second and
um a liquid multiple and the gelatin we
talked about either nox or wamit Valley
gelatin either a half ounce or the the
12 capsules and 5 ounces of the calcium
enrich minute made AR juice all that
together makes up Dr Wall's Pig
arthritis formula and taken Faithfully
twice a day um you have every honest
expectation of getting significantly
better or maybe even 100% better even if
your neck sounds like a bag full of
gravel your joints sound like you have r
nice Crispies in there you know snap
crackle and pop you can't get up out of
your chair yourself you have
excruciating pain and so on you want to
give it a try if you have wearer
arthritis hypertension again we've
already talked about this hypertension
has nothing to do with salt intake salt
restriction is not going to prevent it
or fix it hypertension high blood
pressure is actually due 85% of all
hypertension is due to a Calcium
deficiency take in three times the RDA
recommended daily allowance by your
government and according to the inner
salt study and the study from Toronto
Medical School the calcium will resolve
your high blood pressure insomnia as you
roll around all night wake up in the
morning more tired when you went to bed
contrary to popular belief by physicians
is not due to a barbituate deficiency or
an in or a helon deficiency is due to a
Calcium deficiency kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
the medical profession has the malignant
dumb belief that these things are due to
too much calcium in your diet and the
first advice they give you when you have
any of these problems give up all Dairy
and for God's sake don't take any
supplements with calcium in it when in
fact when you get kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
you have raging osteoprosis it's your
own calcium being moved around you need
more calcium more magnesium not less I
want you to be honest with me how many
of you ever had a foot cramp toe cramp
leg cramp eyelid twitch or anything like
that in your life raise your hand yeah
that's the first symptom of a Calcium
deficiency and if you're honest you'll
you'll fess up to that and myself when I
was a kid when I was a teenager my
eyelids used to Twitch so violently you
could hear them click and I used to look
into the into the mirror and say do
people see that is that my imagination
and one day I got the twitching and the
clicking together and I called my mom
and she came in she didn't know what it
was so she panicked we jumped in the car
and we drove 80 miles to St Louis and I
ran into my first female doctor when I
was 14 years old now remember she's an
ey doctor her name was Mary Jane
skeffington Mary Jane skeffington the
eye doctor for some reason I'm 14 years
old she had me stripped down to my
Jockey
underwear now back then I was just a
dumb redneck kid from the farm and I
didn't know any better whatever she said
I did now today if a eye doctor were to
do that you could go on Heraldo or Oprah
and say you were sexually harassed by
your eye doctor
right but at any rate she kept looking
in my eye with this opthalmoscope for an
hour and then go see another patient
she' look in my eye with opthalmoscope
see another patient he went on and on
and on for two hours and finally said
doc you know listen I play junior
varsity football I'm the captain of the
wrestling team I actually um I'm on the
weightlifting team and if you have to
amputate my eyelids go for it I can
handle whatever you need to do so she
goes into her office she comes back she
has a little Maybelline mascara eyelash
brush and a little mirror in one of
those little plastic boxes and I said
what's that for she says well the
structure of your eyes seems to be okay
but you have these real long eyelashes
they've grown forward hit your eyeg
glasses they've curled back and you're
tickling your eyeball that's what's
causing your eyelids to
Twitch I said you're kidding me she says
no that appears to be what it is and I
said well well what do we do about it
and she says well what I want you to do
is every hour I want you to alternate
eyes take 15 minutes uh in each hour and
work and and retrain those eyelashes and
she starts demonstrating to me she you
know you got to do it like
this I said know wait a minute let's get
this straight you want me to sit on the
football bench with 25
guys weighing over 200b this is a 1950
right and you want me to sit there with
a Maybelline mascara eyelash brush and
play with my
eyelashes and not only does my team have
cleats on their feet there's these guys
across the field 25 guys over 200 lb I
said you got to be crazy so I put on my
pants I said she doesn't know anything
about football right so I went marching
to the school library and I found a
health book out of desperation that was
written by two nurses and I looked in
the index and it said muscle cramps
muscle twitches I looked in the book
where it said to look and sure enough it
said this is all due to a Calcium
deficiency and I said I a't know how to
solve this problem I know where we have
some calcium it's in the calf pellets in
the barn so I ran to the barn I started
filling all my pockets and my pants and
my shirt and my jacket with calf pellets
and the next day at school everybody
else is eating M&M's and jelly beans old
wallak is eating calf pellets because
the alternative was the Maybelline
mascara eyelash
straighten so I was
motivated now in four to five days all
those cramps and Twitches went away all
those cramps and Twitches went away so
when I was 14 years old I knew that
doctors didn't know anything about
nutrition and that eye doctors perhaps
should go back to school and learn some
Anatomy cuz they didn't know where the
eyes
were PMS premenstrual syndrome the
University of California San Diego came
out six years ago and said that 85% of
the emotional and physical stuff a PMs
can be relieved prevented and cured
they're using the Cure word not me by
tripling your intake of calcium over and
above the
RDA now low back
pain that's a pretty common thing low
back pain how many of you yourself or
have known somebody that had a disc
surgery for back pain and still had pain
or more pain after the surgery raise
your hand isn't that amazing almost 40
50% of the people in the room now
Harvard Medical School is getting the
same feedback and they said there's
something wrong with this picture we're
doing these heroic disc surgeries to re
relieve pain and 50% of the people are
still having
pain so they looked at it and they said
okay here's what we're going to do they
took 1,700 people who had no history of
back problems never never had a back
problem and they in the teaching
hospital at Harvard for say cataract
operations 1,700 of them they did CAT
scans on their back 85% of those 1700
people had bulging degenerative and
ruptured disc and Harvard Medical School
eight months ago came out and said if
anybody gets a disc operation for back
pain it's medical fraud because disc
problems do not cause back pain disc
problems can cause tingling numbness and
paralysis but not back pain when you
have low back pain you have cramps and
spasms of large muscle muscles of your
back you can have subluxations or mal
alignments or the vertebrae you can have
bone spurs calcium deposits arthritis
osteoporosis but not dis
problems if you have any of these top 10
problems want to try Dr Wallock Pig
arthritis formula before you you know El
to have any surgery don't be like the
average American who spends between
25,000 and $250,000 and under goes 5 to
10 surgical procedures for nothing more
than the top 10 Calcium deficiency
diseases in America it's really a
terrifying thing that people can be
talked into
that
okay last disease one more slide after
this diabetes the number three killer of
adults United States causes blindness of
all kinds kidney failure kidney dialysis
kidney transplant contributes to the
numbers of cardiov vaster disease the
number one killer of adal in the United
States amputations of toes feet and legs
for ulcers that won't heal and Gang
Green and most times you really don't
have to get an amputation to resolve
those problems but if you insist on
getting something amputated please
please put a tag on it so they get right
one you know if you guys go in for an
inguinal surgery operation you want to
get a do not remove sign and put it in
the appropriate
place that
happens okay now when your doctor
diagnoses a new diabetic patient in his
office he excuses himself goes into his
private office drops to his knees and
gives thanks to the Lord then he jumps
up and he calls his real estate agent
because he knows over for 20 30 40 years
you're going to go through all these
problems if you follow the standard
treatment or management of uh diabetes
in human medicine and as a result over
20 30 40 years you're worth to him
$250,000 to $500,000 is like adding
another cow to the dairy herd they know
exactly how much you're worse to them as
a
diabetic and if you don't think that's
true next time you visit a doctor ask to
see his medical um business office
journals you know they have business
journals for doctors and see what they
say about diabetic patients and heart
patients and cancer patients and how
much on the average that's why people
pick certain Specialties because there's
big bucks in that area now to me this is
Criminal because in 1957 we learned that
we could prevent and cure adult onset
diabetes and animals by supplementing
with two trace minerals chromium and
vadium chromium and
vadium and 11 years ago
1985 the medical school up at British
Columbia Vancouver Canada came out and
said that the trace mineral vadium alone
could replace insulin for adult onset
diabetics who again make up 85% of the
diabetic
population science. dog food contains 40
minerals in a complete analysis always
contains lithium chromium vadium and
selenium Rolston Purina laboratory rat
pellets always contains a minimum of 28
minerals and they always contain lithium
chromium vadium and selenium and I'll
give anybody in this audience a crisp
new $100 bill if you can find me human
infant formula that contains more than
minerals none of them contain lithium
chromium vadium and only one pro Sobe
the one that has 12 has selenium in it
none of the rest do they have 11 10 nine
or eight minerals that's why they call
Similac Similac because it lacks
everything now if I've convinced you
that minerals and nutrition are
important to preventing disease and
adding Health and Longevity to your life
you have to be responsible for this
because your doctor doesn't get 30
seconds worth of clinical nutrition
medical school and as a result this is a
blind spot for them it's something they
never consider when a person comes in
with a Health Challenge they never
consider this aspect of the
disease now you have to know three
things about minerals number one there's
three types of mineral supplements
there's the original going back since
time and Memorial since the beginning of
time there's Elemental or metallic
minerals these are things like Limestone
oyster shell eggshell seabed minerals
Coral Calcium things like um oh Clays of
various types Tums is a modern version
of it 8 to 12% availability to animals
and people we're not designed to consume
ground up rocks if you will to get our
minerals have you ever wondered why
people dread being 50 years old why the
whole population of the world suddenly
falls apart when they hit 50 you know
the teeth get loose the hair goes
whatever you got left is gray low back
problems high blood pressure sugar in
your urine interest in sex goes away
everybody dreads the big five right well
the reason is our ability to absorb
these Elemental types of minerals
precipitously drops to three to 5 per.
about three years ago a guy in Grand
Rapids Michigan jumps up in the back of
the room says hey Doc now I know what I
see in my portapotty business I said
what do you see in your portapotty
business he said well when we clean
those things out and disinfect them so
we can use them again we find hundreds
and hundreds of vitamin pills that come
through people say come on now how do
you know their vitamin pills he well
that's easy they say theeram m one a day
Centrum and Centrum Silver right on the
coating so next time you're on the pot
and you hear plop plop clink clink it's
not poker chips coming through there
it's them
pills are there any chiropractors in the
audience tonight any chiropractors any
chiropractors raise your hand so I can
see I can't see any huh okay well the
reason why I asked that is because
chiropractors take spinal X-rays and
when a chiropractor takes a spinal X-ray
guess what he sees he sees all these
pills lined up and if a person tends to
be constipated those pills line up like
little box cars waiting to come out come
on let me out let me out they want to
get through
a lot of people say to me Doc listen you
know are you kind of fibbing to us a
little bit here pulling our leg I mean
I've taken 2,000 milligrams of calcium
every day for 20 years I take a th000
milligram two of those th milligram
tablets every day for 20 years and I
still have insomnia foot cramps toe
cramps high blood pressure bone spurs
heel spurs arthritis loose teeth my neck
sounds like a bag full of gravel and I
say what kind do you take and they'll
say calcium carbonate calcium gluconate
calcium lactate and that's the problem
problem because out of 1,000 milligram
calcium lactate tablet 86% or 860
milligram is lactose or milk sugar only
14% or 140 milligrams is Elemental or
metallic calcium and let's not use these
complicated numbers up here for
absorption and usability let's take
10% of the um 140 milligrams it's a
honest number and also it's easy math
10% of 140 milligrams is 14 milligrams
so if you take two of those thousand
milligram tablets a day of calcium
lactate or calcium carbonate or calcium
gluconate you're not getting 2,000
milligrams of calcium you're getting 2 *
14 or 28 milligram to get enough to get
enough calcium to get 2,000 milligrams
of usable calcium from a calcium lactate
th000 milligram tablet you have to take
30 of those with each meal you have to
take 90 a day that's almost a full 100
tablet bottle and the cheapest the five
you know five um uh bucks a bottle it's
150 bucks a month just for calcium you
got 59 more minerals 16 vitamins 12
amino acids and three essential fatty
acids to go so this is not a an
efficient way financially to uh take in
minerals because you got all these other
nutrients to deal with plus you got the
plop plop ding-ding Factor you
know and uh additionally you're going to
develop a a another physician caused
disease if they tell you to take this
type of calcium you're going to develop
what I call BNF disease BNF disease
stands for belching and
farting if you take in 90 capsules of
anything a day you're going to develop
BNF disease you're going to sound like
an elephant out in the woods with a
horrible belly
problem and you know you got it when
your spouse has to throw a canary in the
bathroom to see if it's safe to go in
[Applause]
there now during the 60s the animal
industry came up with chelated minerals
because no farmer is dumb enough to put
a dollar in an animal's mouth and have
99 Cents come out in the manure so we
learned by adding amino acids and
proteins and enzymes which are proteins
that do work to the elemental mineral
increases the absorbability from 3 to 5%
to 40% and everybody got excited about
this during the 60s and today because of
this research you'll see a mixture of
Elemental minerals and chelated minerals
and a good multivitamin mineral
supplement you know a tablet but the way
that animals and people are designed to
consume and absorb minerals is in the
colloidal Farm collidal minerals are 98%
available to animals and people 2 and a
half times more available than the kated
minerals 10 times more available than
Elemental or metallic they're liquid in
farm by definition they cannot be
powders and capsules and pills and
tablets they must be liquid small
particle size they're 7,000 times
smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged as one of the
unique things about a colloidal mineral
is they are all negatively charged and
as you know like charges repel so
between being a small particle and they
repel each other they stay in suspension
forever as long as you don't let the
water evaporate now the way it's
supposed to be is
that animals and human beings are
supposed to eat plants and the plants
are supposed to take the elemental
minerals out of the soil convert them to
colloidal minerals for their own use for
their own metabolism and biochemistry we
eat the plants and that's how animals
and people are designed to consume and
absorb minerals in the Plant Farm
colloidal minerals we are not designed
to eat ground up rocks unfortunately US
Senate document 264 1936 says there's no
more minerals left in our farm and Rain
soils un unfortunately in 1992 the Earth
Summit in Rio says there's no more
minerals left in our farm and Rain cells
and plants cannot manufacture minerals
if there's no minerals in the soil they
cannot make they cannot convert these
minerals to collidal minerals and they
cannot manufacture minerals now what
about these long live cultures that were
written up in the National Geographic in
January of 1973 what what's was special
about them is it genetic no they're all
different races they're all different
religions different cultures the
Tibetans from certain Mountain tribes up
there in the Himalayan and the hunzas
and the Eastern Pakistan and the karum
mountains the Russian Georgians azer
Banis abian and the turkistan and the
Caucasus Mountains in R Western Russia
and the vilcabamba Indians from the
Andes of Ecuador and my favorites I just
like to name the titty kakas from the
Andes of
Peru what could possibly be a common
denominator between all these peoples
well there are two number one even
though they're different religions and
different races they were all persecuted
people they were all victims being
chased by the King's Men or Bandits or
whatever and they chose to live in what
would be called the bad lands of their
country I mean horrible nothing no soil
nothing but
Rock and just out of the throw of the
dice nothing that they thought about
they picked places to live in that had
60 to 72 minerals in the parent rock of
the mountains they chose to live in
number two they chose places that had
less than 2 inches of precipitation a
year no rain no snow to speak of so they
had to pick places that had a permanent
water supply and every one of these
cultures picked places that were within
50 to 100 miles of glacier and they all
built aqueducts to carry water from
glaciers to their place where they lived
and worked and
farmed now the water that comes out from
underneath of glaciers is not clear like
tap water perier Evan or glacier water
or geyser water or Calistoga water it's
called glacial milk because the water
that comes out from underneath the
glaciers has so much rock dust or Rock
flour suspended in it that um it's
called glacial milk it looks like whole
milk kind of a bluish White bluish gray
as opposed to clear and if you boil away
a quart of glacial milk you get 2 Ines
of minerals in the bottom of that quart
jug by contrast boil away a quart of
Evan or perier water at 20 bucks a
gallon I mean we're talking price here
compared to gasoline would you ever have
thought that water would be more
expensive than
gasoline kind of interesting isn't it
now you boil away a quart of Evan or
perer water you'll get as much mineral
as you get on the head of a
pin a big contrast now not only do these
people drink this highly Minal miniz
water and get 8 to 12% and 3 to 5% after
age 50 because it's metallic minerals
it's ground up rocks as these glaciers
move up and down the mountains more
important than drinking it they
irrigated with it week after week month
after month year after year generation
after generation for500 to 5,000 years
they irrigated with this glacial milk
they replace literally thousands of tons
of these minerals back into the soil
every year through this irrigation with
this glacial milk and all their plants
are rich with these colloidal minerals
as a result and all we do is put in NPK
NPK NPK and takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete these nutritional minerals from
our soil as a result last year we paid
$1.2 trillion that's with a t $1.2
trillion for Health
Care these people don't get diabetes
they don't get heart disease
osteoporosis arthritis cancer they don't
get glaucoma they don't get cataracts
they don't have birth defects they don't
have jails full of violent criminals and
drug addicts don't have a single
hospital they don't have Blue Cross Blue
Shield major medical hospitalization
they don't have a single doctor and they
don't have these diseases and they live
to be over 120 to
140 now can you live to be over 120 140
without colloidal minerals
no can you get all these colloidal
minerals out of our food supply in the
United States no well can you keep all
the things that we love about the United
States because if I were to pay your way
to go there and live and guarantee you'd
live to be over 100 you wouldn't do it
because they don't have Kenmore kitchens
they don't have electricity they don't
have central heat central air they don't
have roads they don't have cars they
don't have televisions they don't have
television channel Chang I mean how can
you be a couch potato without a
television channel
changer so can you have all these things
we love about America you know including
health
insurance and and still get colloidal
minerals and the answer is of course yes
these colloidal minerals are available
to you they've been around since
1926 and of course they're plant derived
they actually come from an ancient
prehistoric plant deposit um about 1926
there was this this prospector who was
an abysmal failure in Southeastern Utah
who noticed when he even though he
couldn't find gold or silver but he did
notice when he drank this funky tasting
water in the Stream the only water
source available to him after a couple
of weeks his arthritis went away and he
backtracked this stream and he found
that it originated in a prehistoric
Valley that had a forest in it and when
these um trees and brush and grasses
took up all the elemental minerals from
the soil converted them to colloidal
minerals for their own use there was a
cataclysmic event that forest was inomed
that Valley and that forest was inomed
by a volcanic eruption a very thin layer
of mud Ash and lava not heavy enough to
compress this stuff into col or oil and
it was very Aid in there not enough
moisture to fossilize or petrify this
plant material so today if you look at
it it just looks like real dark
chocolate coffee grounds and you squeeze
it between your fingers you squeeze it
between your fingers it uh is the same
consistency as a chocolate chip you
might put in an oatmeal cookie it's kind
of waxy that's because it's not rock
it's groundup plant material we grind
this stuff up into a flower we soak it
in a filtered spring water for four to 6
weeks and we leech those colloidal
minerals out of those plants were taken
up in the prehistoric days things that
you can't get out of your soil and your
food anymore
today and of course that's been around
since 1926 we have liquid multiples that
have been around oh 10 years and one
year and so forth and these are all
available to you also I want to thank
you all very much God bless each and
every one of you and God bless
[Applause]
America it shocks most people when they
learn that we need 90 essential
nutrients we need 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids it's even a
bigger shock to most people when they
learn that man's best friend the dog
gets 40 minerals in his food our
laboratory rats get 28 minerals or less
on his food
and the human infant in their formula
gets 12 or less our dogs get 40 minerals
our rats get 28 and their own kids get
12 or less it's really a dog's life it's
these minerals it's a secret glaciers
grind up these rocks comes out in the
form of glacial milk and these people
have irrigated with this glacial milk
season after season year after year
generation after generation 2500 to
5,000 years depending on the culture the
secret lies in the minerals that come
from these glaciers and these mountains
US Senate document 264 says that our
farm and Rain soils are depleted in
minerals and as a result these crops are
deficient in minerals and as a result of
that animals and people who eat on these
crops get mineral deficiency diseases
when one considers the budget that the
American family puts into their food
each month and the fact that US Senate
document in 264 says there's no longer
any nutrients left in our farm soils and
therefore for in our Foods it's not
outrageous to think of
uh making sure that through a couple of
dollars a day you get all 90 essential
nutrients it's kind of like the modern
version of an apple a day keeps s doctor
away if you really want to find out what
health is like don't wait for the
government don't wait for insurance
don't wait for Medicare and Medicaid to
do it they're not going to do it for you
they can't do it for you even if they
wanted to take control of your own
health do it today don't wait
[Music]
e